I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. We are here with nepotism and a big ol' lift up to start this episode. And we have all the details about it. Welcome to Office ladies. Welcome to Office ladies. It is season seven episode one written by Daniel Chun directed by Jeffrey Blitz. We've got some great Fast Facts today. We really do. And we did a real two-hander on the Fast Facts today. We did
我是珍娜·菲舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了这部终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。我们带着裙带关系和满满的支持开启这一集。我们掌握了关于它的所有细节。欢迎来到办公室女郎。欢迎来到办公室女郎。这是第七季第一集，由丹尼尔·陈编剧，杰弗里·布里茨导演。今天我们有一些很棒的速成冷知识。确实如此。而且我们今天在速成冷知识环节来了一次真正的双人配合。我们是一起
it together. We did. And I loved it. I hope we'll always do it this way. I see what you're doing. Wasn't it fun, ladies? You're like, Ang, this is it. Fast Facts have become a two-hander. Here is your summary. Summer is over. Once again, the cameras did not follow us over the summer for a reason we don't know. Yeah, we don't know. They take the summer off. Dwight now owns Scranton Business Park. He did it. Michael has brought in a new assistant for the office, Luke, but nobody likes him. He's completely incompetent. Michael will not fire him because we find out that Luke is his nephew. Yeah. Gabe and Aaron are dating. Yeah. That happened over the summer when the cameras were off. Yeah. Apparently Gabe checked
完成的。是的。我很喜欢。我希望我们以后一直这样。我知道你在干什么。大家不觉得很有趣吗，女士们？你当时说，安吉，就是这样。速成冷知识已经变成了双人档。以下是本集摘要。夏天结束了。摄像机又一次没有在夏天跟踪拍摄我们，原因我们不得而知。是的，我们不知道。他们放暑假了。德怀特现在拥有了斯克兰顿商业园。他做到了。迈克尔为办公室招募了一个新助理卢克，但没有人喜欢他。他完全是个废柴。迈克尔不肯解雇他，因为我们发现卢克是他的外甥。是的。加布和艾琳在约会。是的。那是夏天摄像机没开的时候发生的。是的。显然加布先跟
in with Andy first about it, and he said it was fine. Yeah. Andy is pretending like he's fine. Uh-huh. And finally, in this episode, Pam is going to play a trick on Dwight because she messed up this sort of long con prank that Jim was working on with Dwight's keys, and she wants to try to make it up to him. Mm-hmm. So that's what's happening this episode. Are we getting the Fast Facts? Yes. See, how excited you are for that because you are part of the Fast Facts. That's not why I'm excited. Look at your enthusiasm. That's not why I'm excited. You could have this every week. Stop. Fast Facts number one. This was our season premiere and also Steve Carell's last season. Like we said last week, before season six
安迪打过招呼，安迪说没问题。是的。安迪假装自己没事。嗯哼。最后，在这一集里，帕姆要对德怀特恶作剧，因为她搞砸了吉姆一直在对德怀特的钥匙进行的长期恶作剧，她想以此来补偿他。嗯哼。这就是这一集发生的事情。我们要开始讲速成冷知识了吗？对。你看你多兴奋，因为你也是速成冷知识的一部分。我兴奋可不是因为这个。看你的热情劲。我兴奋才不是因为这个。你每周都可以有这种待遇。行了。速成冷知识第一条。这是我们的季首播集，也是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的最后一季。就像我们上周说的，在第六季结束前
ended, the cast and crew knew that this would be his last season, but the news was officially announced publicly over the summer break. And there were a lot of opinions about it. Oh, yeah. Mostly people were saying that the office would be dead without Steve. Yeah. This news also put a lot of focus on our season premiere episode. In fact, it was seen by 8.4 million viewers, which was a big bump from our season six finale of 6.6 million. So almost two more million people tuned in. That's a lot. I know. The writers spent a lot of time over the summer talking about how to craft Steve's last season. Their big question was, why does Michael leave Dunder Mifflin? Yeah, because he loves Dunder Mifflin. It's his
剧组和演员们就知道这将是他的最后这一季，但这个消息在暑假期间才正式向公众宣布。大家对此有很多看法。哦，是的。大部分人都在说，没有了史蒂夫，《办公室》就完蛋了。是的。这个消息也把很多焦点聚集到了我们的季首播集上。事实上，有840万观众收看了这一集，比我们第六季大结局的660万有了大幅增长。所以差不多又多了两百万观众收看。这数字真大。我知道。编剧们在夏天花了大量时间讨论如何构思史蒂夫的最后这一季。他们最大的疑问是，迈克尔为什么要离开邓德米弗林？是的，因为他热爱邓德米弗林。这是他的
family. Exactly. Well, Paul Lieberstein said one thing they discussed was Michael getting fired at the end. And we had set this up a little bit with the problems with Saber and the printers. He'd become kind of like the spokesperson. Right. So there was discussion like, maybe that was all going to cave in and he'd have to leave. Yeah. He'd be the fall guy for Saber. Yes. But ultimately they thought that was like not doing right by Michael Scott. They decided that they really wanted him to grow. They wanted him to find love. They wanted him to have a really positive and iconic goodbye. So I listened to the DVD commentary for this episode. By the way, you guys, I have a whole story about what it took
家。没错。保罗·利伯斯坦说过，他们讨论过的一个方案是迈克尔在最后被解雇。我们通过萨博和打印机的那些问题为这一点做了一点铺垫。他有点成了那种代言人。对。所以有过讨论，也许这一切都会崩塌，他不得不离开。是的。他会成为萨博的替罪羊。是的。但最终他们认为那样对不起迈克尔·斯科特。他们决定真的想让他成长。他们想让他找到真爱。他们想让他有一个非常正面且标志性的告别。所以我听了这一集的DVD评论音轨。顺便说一句，伙计们，我有一个完整的故事，讲述了我
for me just to watch a DVD. It was a journey. Amazing, because you were in Texas. Yes. Visiting your family. Yeah. In a very small town. Anyway, I will save that because we have so much to cover, but I have to share later. Anyway, so I finally was able to watch this DVD. It featured Craig Robinson, Creed Bratton, writers Danny Chun, BJ Novak and Paul Lieberstein. Danny, BJ and Paul talked about this being Michael's last season and how they wanted to approach storylines for him. And I found this conversation so interesting. Jenna, we love the whole writer's process. We love it. And they shared that this episode kicked off a change in Michael because his coworkers were his family and him bringing his actual nephew, his actual family into the office,
仅仅为了看一张DVD付出了什么。那真是一段历程。太神奇了，因为你在德克萨斯州。是的。去看望你的家人。是的。在一个非常小的镇上。不管怎样，我先不说了，因为我们要聊的内容太多了，但我等会儿一定要分享。言归正传，我终于看成了这张DVD。里面有克雷格·罗宾逊、克里德·布拉顿、编剧丹尼·陈、BJ·诺瓦克和保罗·利伯斯坦。丹尼、BJ和保罗谈到这是迈克尔的最后这一季，以及他们想如何为他构思剧情线。我觉得这个对话太有趣了。珍娜，我们热爱整个编剧的过程。我们超爱。他们分享说，这一集引发了迈克尔的转变，因为他的同事就是他的家人，而他把真正的外甥、他真正的家人带进了办公室，
he has to try to figure out how to separate work from family. And they also said that they just wanted to show Michael's growth as a person. Here, they say it better than I do. Let's listen. You know, telling Michael that's mixing business and family, these are his two favorite things. Right. So he of all people would not see the problem here. Just couldn't understand. And this was kind of, this came about from us talking about Steve's last season and what are the stories that are kind of quite the central Michael's stories that we just never told. And we were able to kind of have him grow in a way that he wasn't. Yeah. The whole season we would approach Michael finally letting Michael have grown a bit by
他不得不开始琢磨如何把工作和家庭区分开来。他们还说，他们只是想展现迈克尔作为一个人在成长。在这里，他们比我表达得更好。我们来听听。你知道的，告诉迈克尔那是将公事和家庭混为一谈，而这两样正是他最喜欢的两样东西。没错。所以他绝对是那种看不出其中问题的人。就是无法理解。这其实来自于我们对史蒂夫最后一季的讨论，以及那些从未讲述过的、真正核心的迈克尔的故事到底是什么。我们得以让他以一种以前没有过的方式成长。是的。整个这一季，我们对迈克尔的处理方式是，最终让迈克尔在
the end of an episode, which we generally never did. Send him off in style into the grade. Yeah. Because we, you know, we wanted him to be like a more of a whole person by the time he left. Yeah. We knew more or less how he was going to leave. And Yeah. Often up till this season, Michael would just find a new level of denial to end an episode. Right. And that would be funny. But we could start firing off our Michael self-awareness gun, because we knew we only had a few bullets anyway. Yeah. I remember that, that there was this just overall idea of Michael growing into
一集的结尾有所成长，这通常是我们绝不会做的。让他风风光光、体面地离开。是的，因为我们，你知道的，希望他在离开时能更像一个完整的人。是的。我们多多少少知道他会怎么离开。而且是的。通常直到这一季，迈克尔在一集的结尾时只会陷入新一层的否认中。没错。那会很有趣。但我们可以开始发射我们的迈克尔自我意识之枪了，因为我们知道反正子弹有限。是的。我记得当时有这样一个整体理念：迈克尔成长为一个
a man that could leave and Mary Holly, because they knew that was the end. That was the goal. Yes. But we only had one season to get him there now. Right. And it is interesting now as we rewatch this whole season seven, you are going to see Michael becoming more self-aware, more aware of his actions and how they affect other people. Really cool. All right. Fast fact number two, we have a couple of casting announcements. First up, Zach Woods, who plays Gabe, was made a series regular for season seven. We were so happy to have him. And speaking of Michael Scott's nephew, Luke.
能够离开并迎娶霍莉的男人，因为他们知道那是结局。那是目标。是的。但我们现在只有一季的时间让他达到那个状态。没错。现在当我们重温整个第七季时，你会发现很有意思，迈克尔变得越来越有自我意识，越来越能意识到自己的行为以及它们是如何影响其他人的。真的很酷。好了，速成冷知识第二条，我们有几个选角消息。首先是饰演加布的扎克·伍兹，他成为了第七季的常规演员。我们很高兴能有他。说到迈克尔·斯科特的侄子卢克。
Luke was played by Evan Peters. And boy, did we get a fan mail flurry. I bet we did. I mean, Evan's career has just skyrocketed. Oh, yeah. Fan question from Olivia R in St. Louis, Missouri. Hi, ladies. Did you know that Evan Peters grew up in St. Louis? Jenna, he grew up in the suburb of Baldwin. Do you know it? I just love all of the St. Louis connections on the office because I am from there myself. Well, Olivia, yes, I know Baldwin because I grew up in Baldwin. Wait, you and Evan grew up in the same part of town?
卢克由埃文·彼得斯饰演。天哪，我们收到了雪片般的粉丝来信。我敢说绝对是。我是说，埃文的职业生涯简直是火箭式蹿升。哦，是的。来自密苏里州圣路易斯的奥利维亚·R的粉丝提问。嗨，女士们。你们知道埃文·彼得斯是在圣路易斯长大的吗？珍娜，他在鲍德温郊区长大。你知道吗？我太喜欢《办公室》里所有圣路易斯的渊源了，因为我自己就来自那里。噢，奥利维亚，我知道鲍德温，因为我就是在鲍德温长大的。等等，你和埃文在镇上的同一个地方长大？
Yes. Yes. In Baldwin, Missouri, a suburb of St. Louis, not at the same time. I am significantly older than Evan. I wasn't going to say anything. Possible I could be his mother. But yes, Baldwin, Missouri, home of Queenie Park. I'm sure he must have ice skated at Queenie Park. Same as me. Great part of town. How about that? Oh, another fan question from Sierra P in Gresham, Oregon.
是的。是的。在密苏里州的鲍德温，圣路易斯的一个郊区，当然不是同一时期。我比埃文大得多。我本来不想说的。我完全可以当他妈了。不过是的，密苏里州鲍德温，奎妮公园的所在地。我敢肯定他一定在奎妮公园滑过冰。跟我一样。镇上很棒的一个地方。怎么样？哦，来自俄勒冈州格雷厄姆的西娅·P的另一个粉丝提问。
I have to share a monk connection. Monk was randomly on TV the other day and Evan Peters was on. No way. It was season seven, episode two, Mr. Monk and the Genius. No way. I have a connection to Evan. Yeah, I've got a St. Louis connection. You've got a monk connection. Okay, okay.
我得分享一个《神探阿蒙》的渊源。《神探阿蒙》前几天随机在电视上播放，埃文·彼得斯居然在里面。不会吧。那是第七季第二集，《阿蒙先生与天才》。不会吧。我跟埃文有渊源。对，我跟圣路易斯有渊源。你跟《阿蒙》有渊源。好吧，好吧。
Also, lady, he was on house. No way. So we've got another guest star in the house. Oh, you love that pun. It's like your favorite pun. It's going to be my new thing. Every guest star I'm going to see if they were on house. Oh, Lordy. Get ready for it, everyone. You've just got three seasons of me doing that.
还有，女士们，他演过《豪斯医生》。不会吧。所以我们剧组又迎来了一位客串明星。哦，你太喜欢这个双关语了。这简直是你最喜欢的双关语。这要成为我的新标志了。以后每一个客串明星我都要看看他们有没有演过《豪斯医生》。哦，天哪。大家准备好吧。你们接下来要听我玩三个季节这个梗了。
You're probably happy to think of it sooner. And I'm sad. I'll tell you a little bit about Evan, guys. He moved to Los Angeles when he was 15 years old with his mom to pursue his acting career. He landed roles in film and TV productions such as Parenthood, One Tree Hill, The Mentalist, House, Monk. He's probably best known for his work in nine seasons of the American Horror Story anthology and the X-Men film series. Quicksilver. He's Quicksilver. I know. Evan also recently won a Primetime Emmy Award for his work in Mare of Easttown. He was so good in that.
你可能很快就会觉得无聊了。而我很伤心。伙计们，我给你们讲讲埃文的事。他15岁时和妈妈一起搬到洛杉矶追求演艺事业。他获得了许多电影和电视作品的角色，比如《为人父母》、《篮球兄弟》、《超感神探》、《豪斯医生》、《神探阿蒙》。他最著名的作品可能是在《美国恐怖故事》选集九季中的表演以及《X战警》系列电影。快银。他是快银。我知道。埃文最近还凭借在《东城梦魇》中的出色表现获得了黄金时段艾美奖。他在那里面演得太好了。
I was very, I don't want to give a spoiler, but I was very upset. Don't give a spoiler. I know. I know. It wrecked me. You won't say what happened. We won't say. Oh, he was so good in that. With David Denman. Cross-over connection with David Denman. There's another crossover connection.
我非常，我不想剧透，但我当时非常难过。别剧透。我知道。我知道。这把我击垮了。你可别说发生了什么。我们不说。哦，他在里面演得太好了。和大卫·丹曼一起。与大卫·丹曼的联动。还有另一个联动。
Okay. The Office was not his first time working with Steve Carell. They were also in a film together called Sleepover from 2004. I saw that. Is Steve like a mall cop or something? Yeah. He's like a comedic security guard. Yes. And it's basically about these four girls who are having a sleepover and then they go on this wild night out scavenger hunt. And then Evan is part of a group of guys. It's a very comedic role. Like he's very goofy in it. He's one of the high school kids. He has an amazing dance number.
好了。《办公室》并不是他第一次与史蒂夫·卡瑞尔合作。他们还一起出演过2004年的一部名为《睡前故事》的电影。我看过那个。史蒂夫演的是不是像个商场保安什么的？对。他就像个搞笑的保安。是的。故事大致讲的是四个女孩举办睡房派对，然后开始了一场疯狂的夜间寻宝游戏。然后埃文是一群男孩里的一个。这是一个非常搞笑的角色。他在里面非常滑稽。他是高中生之一。他有一段精彩的舞蹈。
I saw that so long ago. I don't think he and Steve had any scenes together in that though. But there is also going to be, after he did his role in The Office, a future crossover connection, which is that he was in the movie Kick-Ass with Clark Duke. Evan, you have so many office crossovers. I know. You can also come hang out with us anytime and you can talk all about it. Yeah. Come on over. Come on over.
那是好久以前看的了。不过我想他在里面和史蒂夫应该没有什么对手戏。但在他演完《办公室》之后，还有一个未来的联动，那就是他和克拉克·杜克一起出演了电影《海扁王》。埃文，你客串过太多《办公室》相关作品了。我知道。你随时都可以来跟我们一起玩，你可以聊个痛快。对，来吧。过来吧。
We'll give you some shortbread cookies and Josh'll bake something. Yeah. And oh, I'll make you a gooey butter cake. There you go. To remind you of home. St. Louis. All right, lady. Do you want a sip of tea or something because... I will. I have made myself a wonderful iced tea because lip dub is about to happen.
我们会给你一些酥饼，乔希会烤点东西。对，哦，我要给你做一个粘稠黄油蛋糕。这就对了。让你想起家乡。圣路易斯。好了，女士。你想喝口茶什么的吗，因为……我会的。我给自己泡了一杯美味的冰茶，因为接下来就要上演对口型假唱了。
That's right. Our fast fact three is going to be breaking down that famous lip dub cold open. We got so many questions about this lip dub. I think we should just go through them one by one. We reached out to a lot of folks to get these answers for you. We did. We were busy. We were. It was fun. It was really fun. I was also just so impressed with how quickly people got back to us.
没错。我们的速成冷知识第三条就是要剖析那个著名的对口型假唱片头。我们收到了太多关于这个假唱的提问。我想我们应该逐一解答。为了给你们这些答案，我们联系了很多人。我们确实联系了。我们很忙。我们是的。这很有趣。真的很有趣。我也对大家回复我们的速度之快印象深刻。
So thank you to everyone we reached out to. Jenna, list them off. We reached out to Randy Cordray, of course. Our cinematographer Matt Sohn, our editor Dave Rogers, Kate Flannery, Creed Bratton. And there was also a great breakdown with our writer Danny Chun and our first AD Kelly Cantley over on office telly.com. And Angela, you got some tidbits from the DVD commentary. So without further ado, let's get started. Question number one.
所以感谢我们联系过的每一个人。珍娜，你来报一下名字。我们联系了兰迪·科德雷，当然还有我们的摄影师马特·松，我们的剪辑师戴夫·罗杰斯，凯特·弗兰内里，克里德·布拉顿。我们的编剧丹尼·陈和第一副导演凯莉·坎特利还在officetelly.com上做过一次精彩的剖析。安吉拉，你从DVD评论音轨里也收集到了一些花絮。所以闲话少说，我们开始吧。问题一。
What was the inspiration for this cold open? Well, first off, lip dubs were very popular at this time. Crazy popular. The idea was like you and a group of friends are a lot of times coworkers, actually. You would film yourself lip syncing to a song and it was supposed to happen all in one take, but moved to various locations. Yeah. I remember one that was going around that everyone was watching was a bunch of office coworkers at a company called Connect Adventures. Oh, yeah.
这个冷首先，那个时候对口型假唱非常流行。火得一塌糊涂。当时的创意就是你和一群朋友——很多时候其实是同事——把自己假唱一首歌的过程拍下来，而且要求一气呵成，但要在不同的地点转换场景。是的。我记得当时在流传、大家都在看的一个视频是一家叫Connect Adventures的公司的一群办公室同事拍的。哦，是的。
And they filmed it one night after work and it was so fun. So guess what? The Dunder Mifflin Gang wants to get in on this. Dunder Mifflin's lip dub starts with Andy in the elevator. He sings Nobody But Me, performed by the human beings. And he dances to the front door of Dunder Mifflin. Someone flips the blinds to read lip dub. Who's that person?
他们有一天晚上在下班后拍的，太有趣了。所以你猜怎么着？邓德米弗林帮也想分一杯羹。邓德米弗林的假唱从安迪在电梯里开始。他唱着《Nobody But Me》，原唱是Human Beings乐队。他一路跳舞来到邓德米弗林的前门。有人拨开百叶窗，上面写着“假唱”（Lip Dub）。那是谁？
Someone did. That would be Pam. The door opens and all of a sudden everyone is dancing in the bullpen. Everyone is on roller skates. It goes all the way through the kitchen, into the break room and back. And it ends with Confetti. And everyone participates pretty much except for Daryl Angela. And Stanley barely participates until the end.
有人这么做了。那是帕姆。门开了，突然所有人都在大办公室里跳舞。每个人都穿着轮滑鞋。镜头一路穿过厨房、休息室，又转回来。最后以彩带收尾。几乎每个人都参与了，除了达里尔、安吉拉。斯坦利直到最后才勉强参与。
And Ryan uses it as an opportunity to promote woof.com. Right. I have to say my favorite part of the lip dub is Kelly in front of the fan. In front of the fan? I just love it. I love Kate strapped to Brian's back, but we'll get to that. Okay. Well, Danny Chun said the writers got the idea to do an office lip dub back in April
而瑞恩趁机宣传了woof.com。不得不说，我最喜欢假唱的部分是凯莉在风扇前面。在风扇前面？我太喜欢了。我喜欢凯特绑在布莱恩背上的那一幕，但我们一会儿会聊到。好吧。丹尼·陈说，编剧们在暑假开始前的4月
or May before the summer break, before the end of season six. He said they'd been just watching lip dubs like we all were. But he thought what I'd love to see is one that's kind of full of mistakes. Yeah. And he said that felt like a fun idea to play with. But Danny said they kind of forgot about the idea for a while. But when it came time to pitch on the season premiere, Danny brought it up again. On the DVD commentary, Danny said that this cold open lip dub was one of the most fun
或5月份、第六季结束前就萌生了制作办公室假唱的想法。他说他们当时一直在看假唱视频，就像我们大家一样。但他心想，我希望能看到一个充满失误的视频。是的。他说这听起来是个很有趣、可以玩味的创意。但丹尼说他们把这个想法搁置了一段时间。不过当到了构思季首播集的时候，丹尼又把这个想法提了出来。丹尼在DVD评论音轨中说，这个假唱片头是他参与过的最有趣的事情
things he's ever been a part of. He said he wrote it in one day and it was originally supposed to start in the parking lot. And then it was going to come through the warehouse and end up in the office. But since none of those buildings are connected in real life, as you know, Jenna. Yes, they could not do it in one take. So our director, Jeff Blitz, suggested it all take place in the main office so that we could do that whole one take look. That leads me into our next question, which was how many takes did you have to do?
之一。他说他只用了一天就写好了，原本剧本设定是从停车场开始。然后穿过仓库，最后到达办公室。但正如你所知，珍娜，现实中这些建筑并不是连在一起的。是的，他们无法一气呵成。所以我们的导演杰夫·布里茨建议所有场景都在主办公室发生，这样我们就能拍出那种一镜到底的效果。这就引出了我们的下一个问题，你们拍了多少条？
And was it really one take or was there some sneaky editing involved? Well, guys, this kind of depends on who you ask. This was very funny. Everyone's memory was a little different on this one. According to Danny Chun, it was one long continuous take and we did it about three or four times. My memory was that it was one long take and I remembered that we did three. Angela, what did you remember? I remembered that it was all one long take as well because it was a domino effect of things.
真的是一镜到底，还是剪辑上耍了什么小聪明？好吧，伙计们，这有点取决于你问谁。这太搞笑了。每个人对这件事的记忆都有点出入。根据丹尼·陈的说法，这是一个超长的连续镜头，我们大概拍了三四次。我的记忆是这是一个超长的镜头，我记得我们拍了三次。安吉拉，你记得是什么样的？我的记忆也是整个镜头一气呵成，因为这就像多米诺骨牌效应一样。
So I was there in Daryl's office and I had to shut the door, but me shutting the door cued Andy to say, go, go, go. So I just remember all of these moments and we did it all in one take. But I do remember that we got it pretty quickly. We were impressed with ourselves. We were like, oh my gosh, we got that. Yeah, same memory. Well, when we reached out to cinematographer Matt Stone, he confirmed that we did do this as one long continuous take.
当时我在达里尔的办公室里，我得把门关上，而我关门的动作就是给安迪的暗号，让他喊“走，走，走”。所以我只记得所有这些连贯的时刻，而且我们确实是一条过的。不过我确实记得我们过得挺快的。当时我们还挺佩服自己的。我们心想，噢天哪，我们居然一条过了。是的，记忆一样。好吧，当我们联系摄影师马特·松时，他证实我们的确是作为一个超长的连续镜头拍摄的。
However, he said that they did work in a couple of spots where we could cut if we needed to, but we did shoot it as one long take. So then when we reached out to our editor Dave Rogers, he actually went back and checked his files. He said we did five takes and he sent them to us. Amazing. He said we used a combination of take four and take five. So he said it's mostly all take five, but we cut when Angela slams Daryl's office door and then we cut on the whip to take four as the camera moves by Phyllis dancing and heads into Michael's office as he performs the magic tricks with his wand. And then we whip out back to take five as Andy yells streamers and then we stayed and take five until the end.
不过，他说他们确实安排了几个可以在必要时进行剪辑的节点，但我们的确是按一个长镜头来拍的。然后当我们联系我们的剪辑师戴夫·罗杰斯时，他真的回去检查了他的文件。他说我们拍了五条，并把它们发给我们了。太神奇了。他说我们结合使用了第四条和第五条。所以他说基本上全都是第五条，但在安吉拉“砰”地关上达里尔办公室门的那里剪辑了一下，然后切到第四条的摇镜头，随着镜头从跳舞的菲莉丝身边掠过，进入迈克尔的办公室，看他在里面用魔杖变魔术。然后我们又切回第五条，当安迪大喊彩带时，我们就一直留在第五条直到结束。
And Dave said, looking at all the takes, he thinks the reason we did this was because Steve's magic in his office was best and take four. And they really wanted that magic take in the episode. I just have to give a big thank you to Dave Rogers because we all had different memories and he had the answer. Yeah, thank you, Dave. Incidentally, in terms of Michael's magic, Danny Chun shared that they basically just gave Steve a bunch of dorky magic tricks and let Steve improvise it. So each of those magic takes in his office were a little bit different except for the fire part. Yeah, they had a magician's helper named Amos Levkovich. He was hiding behind Michael's door to preset that flame trick at the end.
戴夫说，查看了所有的镜头后，他认为我们之所以这么选，是因为史蒂夫在办公室里的魔术在第四条里表现得最好。他们真的很想把那个魔术镜头放进剧集里。我必须好好感谢戴夫·罗杰斯，因为我们大家的记忆各不相同，而他掌握着正确答案。是的，谢谢戴夫。顺便说一句，关于迈克尔的魔术，丹尼·陈透露，他们基本上只是给了史蒂夫一堆滑稽的魔术小道具，然后让史蒂夫即兴发挥。所以他办公室里的每一个魔术镜头都有点不同，除了玩火的那部分。是的，他们当时有个魔术师助手叫阿莫斯·列夫科维奇。他藏在迈克尔的门后面，提前设置好了最后的火焰把戏。
So here were all of Michael's tricks. A dove comes out of his wand, flowers appear out of his cane, and then of course that flame in his hand. I remember Steve loved that dove coming out of the wand. And he does it like three times. I know. It's so funny. All right, let's see. Next question.
所以迈克尔的戏法有这些：魔杖里飞出一只鸽子，手杖里变出鲜花，然后当然就是他手上的火焰。我记得史蒂夫特别喜欢从魔杖里飞出鸽子那一幕。他连着做了三次。我知道。太搞笑了。好吧，我们看下一个问题。
How did they choose which song to use? Well, that was all Danny. It was the only song he considered. He said he really wanted a song that was, quote, short, upbeat, fun to lip sync to and not too current. Randy said it cost us $50,000 to get the song rights. And we should probably add that we could really hear that song. They had speakers like hidden all around the set and it was really playing the song. We were really doing like lip syncing.
他们是怎么选择这首歌的？好吧，全都是丹尼的主意。这是他考虑过的唯一一首歌。他说他真的想要一首歌，引用他的话说，“简短、欢快、适合假唱且不太过时”。兰迪说我们花了5万美元才买下这首歌的版权。我们可能还应该补充一点，我们真的能听到那首歌。他们在片场各处藏了扬声器，音乐是真的在播放。我们当时确实是在假唱。
Yeah. And I mean, I don't think you can fake that, that kind of energy that a song brings. I was so glad that they were playing it throughout the office. Yes. Our next questions are who came up with the choreography and what was the rehearsal process like? This was heavily choreographed, you guys. So the lip dub was choreographed by Mary Ann Kellogg. She planned it out with a team of dancers.
而且我是说，我觉得你没法假装出那种由一首歌带来的活力。我很高兴他们把歌声在整个办公室里播放。是的。我们的下一个问题是，谁想出的编舞？排练过程是怎样的？这可是经过精心编排的，伙计们。所以这个假唱是由玛丽安·凯洛格编舞的。她和一整个舞蹈团队一起做好了规划。
They shared on the DVD commentary that every single detail you see was planned. Randy Cordray even sent us their rehearsal video. I loved watching it, Jenna. Me too. They had all these dancers doing our parts. Way better than we did them by the way. Like real dancers. They were amazing.
他们在DVD评论音轨里分享说，你看到的每一个细节都是计划好的。兰迪·科德雷甚至给我们发了他们的排练视频。我看得津津有味，珍娜。我也是。他们让所有的舞者排练我们的部分。说实话，跳得比我们好多了。就像真正的舞者一样。他们太棒了。
The rehearsal dancers need a shout out. They were Tammy Toh, Lauren Marie Menendez, Michael Catherine Pina, Jennifer Mimi Karsh, Aaron Cash and John Todd. They were so great. We couldn't have done this without them. Randy Cordray said we can put the rehearsal in our Insta stories so you guys can watch it. And Danny said they had scripted out all the beats, but there were little things that were tricky. For example, getting Aaron from reception to the kitchen in time, or the fact that he wrote in the script that Meredith is strapped to Kevin's back in the break room.
排练舞者们值得大声夸奖。他们是塔米·托、劳伦·玛丽·梅嫩德斯、迈克尔·凯瑟琳·皮纳、詹妮弗·咪咪·卡什、亚伦·卡什和约翰·托德。他们太棒了。没有他们我们可完成不了。兰迪·科德雷说我们可以把排练视频发到我们的Instagram快拍里，这样你们大家也能看了。丹尼说他们把所有的节奏都写进剧本了，但有一些小地方很棘手。比如，让亚伦及时从前台赶到厨房，或者他在剧本里写了梅雷迪思在休息室里被绑在凯文的背上。
Oh yeah, he just wrote that down. Yeah. But how to make that happen? Exactly. Kelly Cantley shared that our special effects coordinator, Mike Thompson, built the harness that Kate had to wear. And you guys, I reached out to Kate because I was like, Kate, will you please tell me about being strapped to Brian's back? How did you do it? What was the process?
哦对了，他随手就写上去了。是的。但怎么才能实现呢？没错。凯莉·坎特利分享说，我们的特效统筹迈克·汤普森制作了凯特必须穿的背带。伙计们，我联系了凯特，因为我说：“凯特，能跟我讲讲被绑在布莱恩背上是什么感觉吗？你们是怎么做到的？过程是怎样的？”
Here's what she had to say. Hey, it's Kate Flannery. Okay, so this is the deal. I was on a harness on Brian's back. There was a table behind us so that I wasn't putting all my weight on him the entire time. I would squat on the table, even though it was high up, just to get my weight off of his back. Like, don't break another actor. Don't do it.
她是这么说的。嘿，我是凯特·弗兰内里。好吧，情况是这样的。我绑在布莱恩背上的背带里。我们身后有一张桌子，这样我就不用把全身的重量一直压在他身上了。我蹲在桌子上，虽然位置挺高，但至少能把我的体重从他背上卸下来。就好像，别把另一个演员压垮了。千万别。
Anyway, so I'm on his back on this crazy harness, and then he turns around, and I have the word nobody on my stomach. Okay, the first time we do it, it's perfect. The whole thing was perfect. You guys, there's no cut in a lip dub. It has to be all one take, so everybody has to get their part right, everybody. And we did, except that they felt like my nobody was too faded. The marker had, like, absorbed into my skin, so I feel like I let everybody down. So we had to do, I think we did two more takes for safety, but I still feel like we would have had it on the first one if you could read my nobody.
不管怎样，我戴着这个疯狂的背带趴在他背上，然后他转过身来，我的肚子上写着“nobody”（无名之辈）这个词。好吧，第一次排练时，完美。整个过程完美无缺。伙计们，假唱是没有剪辑的。必须一镜到底，所以每个人都必须把自己的部分演对，每个人。我们做到了，除了他们觉得我肚子上的nobody字迹太褪色了。记号笔好像被我的皮肤给“吸收”了，所以我觉得我让大家失望了。因此我们不得不，我想我们为了安全起见又拍了两条，但我觉得如果我的nobody能被看清楚的话，我们第一条就成了。
So my pasty white skin absorbed the Sharpie. It was, yeah, it took a couple days for it to come off. I'll be honest with you, it's kind of weird to look in the mirror when you're taking a shower or getting dressed, and your stomach says nobody. Don't try this at home, folks. She said that nobody, they had to go back and ride it over and, you know, really darken it, and it was there for days. Well, I loved this day. I remember we came in early and we rehearsed, and then we went to hair and makeup, and I remember Randy told us we had the whole day. We should just take the day.
所以是我苍白粗糙的皮肤把马克笔的墨水吸收了。这确实花了好几天才洗掉。老实说，当你洗澡或穿衣服照镜子时，发现自己的肚子上写着“nobody”，这种感觉确实有点诡异。大家千万别在家模仿。她说那个“nobody”字眼，他们必须重新回去描粗，而且好几天都没洗掉。不过我太喜欢那天了。我记得我们一大早就来排练，然后去化了妆，我还记得兰迪告诉我们我们有一整天的时间。我们可以慢慢来。
Right, no stress. Yeah, and all the dancers were there. We watched their video, and then whoever was dancing our part would show us our part. And show us the timing. Yes. So Randy told me that, yes, we started rehearsing at 7.15 in the morning. We got our first take at 11.23. That's the precision of Randy Cordray.
对，完全没有压力。是的，所有舞者都在场。我们看了他们的视频，然后谁跳我们的部分就会教我们。教我们节奏。是的。所以兰迪告诉我，没错，我们早上7点15分开始排练。我们在11点23分完成了第一条。这就是兰迪·科德雷的精确度。
He knows the exact moment. He's like an air traffic controller. Your flight will leave at 7.12. Okay. Exactly. All right, Randy. And we wrapped for the day at 1.36. And it was just so much fun.
他连具体时间都知道。他就像个空中交通管制员。你的航班将在7点12分起飞。好吧。完全正确。好吧，兰迪。我们在下午1点36分收工。而且真的太好玩了。
That's an early wrap day for us, you guys. So that meant we had the whole afternoon. We were probably so excited. I know. I remember our biggest hurdle was that there was a big cleanup between each take with all the streamers and everything. But besides that, we were able to really go through those takes pretty quickly. Angela, I got a fan question from Ian O. in South Africa and Diana T. in Paris, France
对我们来说这是个很早收工的日子，伙计们。这意味着我们有整整一个下午的时间。我们当时可能兴奋极了。我知道。我记得我们最大的障碍是每拍完一条，都要花时间清理满地的彩带和其他道具。除此之外，我们确实能相当快地拍完整体。安吉拉，我收到了来自南非的伊恩·O和法国巴黎的迪安娜·T的粉丝提问。
to international folks who are wondering, Angela, were you bummed that you couldn't really participate in the lip dub festivities? I mean, you know me in real life. I wanted to be on those roller skates. I wanted to zip through. I was so excited. It looks so fun. But it made sense that my character would not want to participate.
这两位国际粉丝想知道，安吉拉，对于自己不能真正参与到假唱的欢乐中，你是不是觉得很沮丧？我的意思是，你在现实生活中了解我。我当时特别想穿上那些轮滑鞋。我特别想滑来滑去。我太兴奋了。看起来太好玩了。但我的角色不想参与其中，这确实合乎情理。
But I still got to be in it. I was glad that at least I had that little moment with Daryl. And I yelled at the camera and slammed the door. So we were in there the whole time. And as the camera went past us into the kitchen, we got a little bit of a break. But I have a great memory of that day because it was pretty relaxing. I didn't actually have to do any heavy lifting in the lift up. I kind of got to watch it.
不过我还是参与进去了。我很庆幸自己至少和达里尔有那么一小段戏。我对着镜头大喊大叫，还“砰”地关上了门。所以我们全程都在那里。当镜头从我们身边掠过进入厨房时，我们稍微休息了一下。但我对那天有一个美好的回忆，因为其实相当轻松。我在假唱里其实不需要做什么重体力活。我有点像是在一旁观看。
And you know, Craig is such an easy person to hang out with. We had a fun time. We were sort of like the goldfish in the glass bowl, like watching the humans go by. Jenna, what about you? Did you have fun? You got to dance and you love to dance. You got to do a shimmy. I know.
而且你知道的，克雷格是个很好相处的人。我们过得很开心。我们有点像玻璃鱼缸里的金鱼，看着人类从眼前走过。珍娜，你呢？你玩得开心吗？你得跳舞，而且你很喜欢跳舞。你还得扭扭摆摆。我知道。
But you had to go backwards. Was that hard? That was really tricky. So it was a little stressful because Ed and I had to start it off. And if we didn't start off with the right timing, then forget it. We should just not even continue. And that's really me pulling the blinds. And then I had to dance backwards into a very specific spot where I'm hiding
但你得倒着走。那很难吗？确实非常棘手。所以这其实有点压力，因为我和埃文必须负责开场。如果我们开场的节奏不对，那就全完了。我们甚至都不用继续下去了。而且那确实是我在拉百叶窗。然后我必须倒着跳舞到一个非常具体的位置，在那里我要把藏在我身后的
people behind me who can jump out. Yeah. So that was like a big choreography between me and Matt Stone, our camera operator. And you can see me glance out of the corner of my eye because I was worried I was going to run into the little chair at reception when I'm going back. If you look closely, I had to look. I was really afraid I was going to run into it. But I think all of those moments work because exactly what Danny said.
人放出来，让他们跳出来。是的，这对我来说和我们的摄像师马特·松之间有非常复杂的编舞配合。你可以看到我用眼角余光瞥了一眼，因为我担心往后退的时候会撞到前台的小椅子。如果你仔细看，我必须看。我真的很害怕撞上去。但我认为所有这些时刻之所以能起作用，正是因为丹尼说的那句话。
This is like paper company. I bet Danny would have loved it if I ran into the chair. Yeah, exactly. You would have been like, that's fine. Yeah. But yes, like you said, it was really, really choreographed except at the end, that stuff of us, we're just improvising and dancing and throwing streamers and stuff.
这就像是造纸公司。我敢打赌，如果我撞到椅子上，丹尼肯定会乐坏的。是的，完全如此。你会觉得，“没关系，挺好。”是的。但正如你所说，除了最后大家开始即兴发挥、跳舞、抛撒彩带之类的那部分，前面真的、真的是经过精心编排的。
And so that was a relief once we got to that point. We also, speaking of that ending part, had a fan catch from Cecily G. in New Mexico at two minutes and 19 seconds. I have a cheesy John Krasinski jumping up and down catch. She said he's doing his busting out some of his dance moves. Yeah. The same kind of stuff he did in Cafe Disco. I looked for it and it's great.
所以一旦到了那个环节，我们就彻底放松了。说到最后那个部分，我们还收到了新墨西哥州的西茜·G的粉丝纠错，在两分十九秒处。我发现了一个搞笑的约翰·卡拉辛斯基上下跳跃的彩蛋。她说他在那儿大秀舞姿。是的。就像他在《迪斯科咖啡馆》里做的那种动作。我特意去找了一下，真的很棒。
I'll have to go look for it. I was really curious about Creed playing the guitar. Yeah. Because you know, Creed comes over to my house and plays the guitar all the time. Yeah. The man's amazing. So I reached out to him and I said, Creed, are you really playing that part of the song? Are you really playing the guitar?
我回头也得去看看。我对克里德弹吉他那段特别好奇。是的，因为你知道的，克里德经常来我家弹吉他。是的。这老爷子太厉害了。所以我联系了他，我说：“克里德，你在那首歌里是真的在弹吗？你真的在弹吉他吗？”
What's happening here? He said, and I'm not actually playing that. I'm approximating what the notes would look like and it looks real because I can actually play the guitar, but I'm not synced up to where the music would be. Oh, interesting. Yeah. Oh. So, fakey playing by a real person who can play on a real guitar.
这到底是怎么回事？他说，其实我并不是真的在弹。我只是在模拟按弦的动作，看起来很真实，因为我确实会弹吉他，但我弹得并没有和音乐同步。哦，有趣。哦。原来是由一个真正会弹吉他的人进行的一场假弹表演。
It really looked to me like he was playing the notes exactly. Yeah. I'm impressed. Well, our final question is this. Was Toby really behind the camera or was his voice added in post? His voice was added in post. Yeah. It was operated by our cinematographer Matt Sohn.
在我看来，他弹的音符简直天衣无缝。是的。我佩服得五体投地。好吧，我们的最后一个问题是这样的。托比当时真的是在摄像机后面，还是他的声音是后期加上去的？他的声音是后期加的。是的。摄像机是由我们的摄影师马特·松操作的。
I don't even think Paul was standing behind the camera that day. I don't have a memory of it. Paul, I'm sorry. Were you there? You're so quiet. I do love though that they made it Toby's voice because by doing that, then the whole entire office participated. Yes.
我甚至不觉得保罗那天站在摄像机后面。我一点印象都没有了。保罗，对不起。你在场吗？你太安静了。不过我确实很喜欢他们把这个声音设计成托比的，因为通过这种方式，整个办公室的所有人都参与进来了。是的。
Yes. Kelly Cantley shared that she walked around the room with Matt while they were filming. Also our boom operator, Brian Whittle. And I totally remember that. Kelly was like, it's like she had the outline of the whole thing and she had a stopwatch. Like she was like, let's go. Yeah. They were like this little trio clump just kind of moving through.
是的。凯莉·坎特利分享说，拍摄时她一直和拿着摄像机的马特一起在房间里走动。还有我们的收音师布莱恩·惠特尔。我完全记得这一点。凯莉当时的状态就像是，她手里拿着整个流程的大纲，还拿着一个秒表。就像她在说，我们走吧。是的。他们就像一小团人，一边移动一边配合。
Keeping us on track. But we also had our second AD Stephanie hiding behind the reception desk. She was giving cues. Our PA Chuck was hiding behind that door over by accounting that nobody goes in. And I remember he would peek out and give the cue when the guys were coming back in through the kitchen so we could be ready. It was just, it was this whole machine and some of the dancers were hidden to kind of remind us what we were supposed to do.
确保我们按计划进行。但我们还有第二副导演斯蒂芬妮藏在前台桌子后面。她负责给暗号。我们的制片助理查克藏在会计部旁边那个没人进的门后面。我记得他会探出头来，在男生们从厨房回来时给出暗号，好让我们准备好。这真是一台庞大的机器，有些舞者藏在暗处，用来提醒我们接下来该做什么。
The magician was hidden. Gosh, I wish we had like actual documentary footage of all the people it took to pull this off. Yeah. You guys, thanks so much for sending in your questions. That was really fun to break down. It was so much fun to do. I rewatched that so many times this week, Jenna.
魔术师也藏起来了。天哪，我真希望我们能有把这一切拍下来的幕后纪录片素材。是的。伙计们，非常感谢你们发来提问。剖析这一段真的太有趣了。做这一期节目太开心了。珍娜，这周我把那段看了好几遍。
It made me happy every time. Me too. What a fun thing we got to do. I know. We were so lucky. Well, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, I have to share the journey I went on to find a DVD player that could play a Blu-ray disc in Archer City, Texas.
每次看都让我心情大好。我也是。我们能拍到这么好玩的东西真是太幸运了。我知道。我们太幸运了。好吧，我们为什么不休息一下呢？等我们回来，我得跟大家分享我在德克萨斯州阿彻城寻找一台能播放蓝光光盘的DVD播放器所经历的艰辛历程。
I was on that journey with you, Angela, via text message. You were. And it is quite a journey. It is. And then, of course, let's talk nepotism because, oh man, does a lot happen in this episode. Some corporate punishment. Oh. All right, we are back.
安吉拉，我通过短信陪你经历了这段旅程。你确实陪着。这真是一段不小的旅程。确实。然后，当然了，我们来聊聊裙带关系，因为天哪，这一集里发生了太多事。一些企业惩罚。哦。好了，我们回来了。
And Angela, you have to share the story about watching the DVD in Texas. And for some context, I just want to say this to preface. We have been recording this podcast now for three years. Three years, lady. I can't believe it's been three years. And I am still so impressed at the lengths that you will go to prep an episode. Even when you did not have the tools readily available. I mean, I'm just really proud of us.
安吉拉，你得跟大家分享在德克萨斯州看DVD的故事。为了做点铺垫，我想先说这么一句。我们录制这个播客到现在已经三年了。整整三年了，女士。我简直不敢相信已经三年了。而且我依然对你为筹备一集节目所付出的努力深感钦佩。甚至在你手头没有现成工具的时候。我是说，我真的为我们感到骄傲。
I feel the same way about you. I have talked to you while you have been hiding in a bathroom with your laptop while at, like, a family reunion. So you're trying to get some time, some work done. So you guys, we love doing this podcast and we'll do it from wherever we can. That's right. So here's my story of how I watched the DVD commentary for nepotism. I knew I would be in my hometown of Archer City, Texas, very small town in North Texas.
我对你也有同感。我曾跟你通过电话，当时你正躲在家族聚会某个地方的浴室里用笔记本电脑工作。你就是想挤出点时间把活儿干完。所以伙计们，我们太喜欢做这个播客了，不管身在何处我们都会坚持做下去。没错。所以这就是我关于如何观看《裙带关系》DVD评论音轨的故事。我知道我要回老家德克萨斯州阿彻城，那是德克萨斯州北部的一个小镇。
Population, according to the last census, 1,601. Everybody knows everybody in Archer City. Everybody knows everyone and they're all willing to chip in. So before I went, I asked my sister, Janet, I said, hey, do you have the DVD box set? She's like, oh, I have one somewhere. So I was like, okay. She goes, no, I know it's here. I said, okay.
根据最近的人口普查，人口是1601人。阿彻城里每个人都认识所有人。每个人都认识所有人，而且大家都愿意搭一把手。所以在去之前，我问我姐姐珍妮，我说：“嘿，你有DVD套装吗？”她回答说：“哦，我随手放在哪儿了。”所以我当时想，好吧。她说：“不，我知道它在这儿。”我说，好吧。
So my sister finds her old box set. Jenna, it was the Blu-ray, the Blu-ray old box set. They don't even make them anymore. Yes. I started getting texts from Angela about eight in the morning and I get this text. Oh my God, my sister has the box set, but it's Blu-ray. And we can't figure out how to get it to work in my mom's DVD player. And then you wrote, I don't think it's been used in a decade.
于是我姐姐找到了她的旧套装。珍娜，那是蓝光版，蓝光旧套装。现在都不生产了。是的。我大概早上八点开始收到安吉拉发来的短信，我收到了这样一条短信。天哪，我姐姐有这个套装，但它是蓝光的。我们不知道怎么在我妈妈的DVD播放器上播放。然后你写道，我觉得它十年没用过了。
Oh no, it hadn't. They were not compatible. They were not compatible. And not only that, we started using old remotes completely messed up my mom's DVD. Oh no. And you were like, now you're like a little, not panicking, but you're like, what am I going to do? This was my prep day.
哦不，确实十年没用了。它们不兼容。它们根本不兼容。不仅如此，我们开始用那些旧遥控器，结果彻底把妈妈的DVD机给弄乱了。哦不。然后你当时有点，也不是恐慌，但你会想，我该怎么办？这是我的备采日。
Yeah. So then my sister Billy's like, come on over. Try mine. I got that text, 8.30. My sister Billy has a DVD player I'm going to head to her house. Yeah. And then it was like radio silence. I did not hear from you until 11.30 when you said, nope, that didn't work.
所以然后我姐姐比利说，过来吧。试试我的。我8点30分收到了那条短信。我姐姐比利家有个DVD播放机，我正赶去她家。是的。然后就像无线电静默一样。直到11点30分我才收到你的消息，你说，不行，那个也不管用。
Headed to the elementary school. And I'm like, what? Yeah. What is happening? Okay. Third location. Third location. I get to the elementary school.
正赶往小学。我就想，什么？是的。到底怎么了？好吧。第三个地点。第三个地点。我到了小学。
My sister is a school teacher. She was up there preparing her classroom for the upcoming school year. She was like, maybe there'll be one here. And then she opened the door for me. She was like, Angela, I think we've downloaded a program that will work on my desktop to play the Blu-ray. She downloaded a program. I know.
我姐姐是个学校老师。她当时正在那里为即将到来的新学年布置教室。她当时想，也许这里会有一个。然后她为我开门。她对我说：“安吉拉，我想我们在我的台式电脑上下载了一个能播放蓝光光盘的程序。”她竟然下载了一个程序。我知道。
So I sit in the elementary school principal's office and it didn't work. So now they're like, okay, let's try one of the classrooms. I go into my sister's classroom. Now PE teachers, Chris and Julie, and another pre-K teacher, Miriam is in there. We're all trying to make my sister's laptop work. It won't play it. And finally, to the rescue, Amanda, the librarian, she says, I think we have a Blu-ray display in the elementary school library.
But here's the thing. It's closed because it's summer and it was 114 degrees that day. That library was super hot and stuffy, but they opened it up. And guess what? It did work. It played the Blu-ray. And then I get this video of you, Angela, that you sent me at 1245. This is like four hours later of you sitting and watching the DVD commentary, and they
even brought you a fan. You're sitting in front of a fan. I'm sitting on the floor in the little reading nook of the elementary school library. And that is where I prepped this episode. Thank you so much to the ladies at the Archer City Elementary School for helping me watch nepotism. Amazing. I was very impressed with your tenacity that day, Angela.
Thank you. It was like a whole town helped you watch the DVD. So we dedicate this episode of Office Ladies to Archer City, Texas. Thank you. I noticed something at the very top of this episode, lady. New opening credits. We added a bunch of new shots. They did this because it was our season premiere episode.
We had these big, long, extended credits. We're going to have shorter credits moving forward, but we do keep these new shots of Michael Dwight, Pam Jim, Ryan and Andy. And we will always end with Michael moving the dundee on his desk. There's a little bit of opening credits trivia I heard on the commentary. The commentary is already paying off. While sitting in the elementary school library, they shared that we will have new opening credits every time Dunder Mifflin gets a new boss moving forward.
Oh. How about that? Okay. We'll be on the lookout for that. Yes. Well, Michael is going to arrive to work and he has a talking head. He says, sadly, summer had to come to an end. You guys, a lot happened.
He got West Nile virus, then he stepped on a piece of glass in a parking lot. That hurt. He peed on it and he was surprised it got infected. And maybe he saw inception. I mean, what a summer. So under all of this, we see various shots of Michael. And one of them is a very simple swish pan over to a fall tree, a tree with beautiful autumn colors.
Yeah. It seems really out of place. It seems like a big old fakie tree. Guess what, lady? What? It was a big old fakie tree, but it was in the script. There was a script note that came along with Michael's talking head that said this. Michael gets out of his car.
Something catches his eye. He looks over at a tree with brilliant autumn colors. He sighs forlorn, if not angry, at this autumn tree. What a narrative. Well, Randy Cordray said to get this autumn tree was quite an ordeal. Just this little script note. He said we shot this on August 2nd in 2010. There were no trees with fall colors to be found anywhere in the United States of America.
Anywhere. They couldn't fly one in from anywhere. Nothing in Vermont. I don't know. Do the trees start changing that early, early August? Well, I am the last person to ask that question. I'm sure there's listeners in Vermont right now going, lady, lady. She said, there is a place that you can go in Hollywood.
It's called Green Set, and they have amazing trees, shrubs, and landscape decor for any budget, and they have fakie fall trees. I went on their website. Once again, I was clearly meant to be some sort of product or set deck in another life. They have fakie box hedges and real box hedges. This place, in addition to fakie hedges, also has animal statues. You can rent. What?
Yeah. Come on. If you want to put a big tiger in your yard, they also have glacier walls. What? I don't know if you're doing a movie or something and you need to look like you're standing in front of a glacier or if you have a theme party about ice climbing. I'm getting so excited. If you guys ever take office ladies on the road, please use that as stage backdrop.
Like a giant glacier wall? Yeah, depending on what state you're in. Are the tiger? Yes. Oh, my gosh. That's amazing. And then everyone can see what we were talking about in this episode. Here's your glacier wall.
Now I just want to say, I'm still talking about this tree because in addition to having to find this fakie tree, Randy said there was more. Just for this little swish shot. What more? He said they had to shoot very early in the morning. Okay. They had to rent a special light to backlight this tree. It was called a 10K.
It has 10,000 watts of light. Just for this one sentence in a script. Yes. Because they wanted it to look like it was early morning sun coming through the colorful leaves to highlight these leaves and set them apart from everything around them. This is that moment as a writer where I'm like, do you think Danny was like, oh, we could have lost the autumn tree? Yeah.
I mean, I don't know if it was all that much work. Well that's Randy's job is to like go through the script. And then I think sometimes he'll have to go to production. He'll be like, okay, here's the thing. You can either have your lip dub song or the autumn tree. Pick. I mean, I don't have the budget for all of it. Or sometimes he finds a way to make it all work, which is amazing.
Which is usually the case. So what happens next, Ange? Andy is going to be chatting up Aaron and then Gabe walks in. Yes. We find out that Aaron and Gabe have started dating over the summer. Gabe says it has been in a word exquisite. Then Aaron has a talking head that sounds like she only said yes because she thought she had to because Gabe was her boss, which makes me real sad.
Yes. But now she seems to enjoy her relationship with him. It seems. It seems. Andy has a talking head where he says he's all right with it. He's on a nice beach at Cape Cod, gazing out across the White Caps. That's his anger management. That's right.
But oh look, it's a humpback whale who's eating Gabe. Well, I also watched in the elementary school library, the deleted scenes. And there were a ton of deleted scenes where everyone shares what they did over the summer. Oh, it was a much bigger runner. It is hilarious. I'm going to save and share it later. Okay. Hint, hint.
It's about Kevin. Well, Pam is adjusting the thermostat and Dwight comes up and locks it up. Yeah. He says if she's so hot, she can just sit on a nice pack. Thanks Dwight. Can we talk about the hydration backpack that Dwight has on? He requires hands-free hydration, Angela. I know.
I looked it up. It's called a camelback hydration pack. They have many options of these online. And I'm quoting the internet here with minimal storage space. This pack is best for quick hikes or trail runs that won't require a ton of gear. And the two-liter reservoir capacity ensures you'll have enough water for your trip. Danny said something on the commentary that really made me laugh. He said, I wish that Dwight had worn that camelback backpack for the rest of the season.
I was like, oh man, me too. I see people with those on all the time when we're skiing. Oh. And honestly, I think next season I'm going to get one. Yeah. Because you've got to stay hydrated on the slopes, lady. And there's nowhere to put a bottle of water. Please tell me if you wear one of those that you'll take a picture and send it to me because
I need that image in my life. Dwight has my favorite talking head of this episode. He says Dwight Shrewt, star salesman, beat farmer, bed and breakfast proprietor, aspiring freelance bodyguard, add to that list owner of this building, then burn the list. And then he takes a big swig out of the little hose. Like, he looks like a four-year-old with a sippy cup. He really does. I love Kelly's talking head.
Oh, and talk about a new look. Oh yeah, corporate sassy Kelly. Well, the reason for that, lady, is because she did the Minority Executive Program at Yale. She says you don't even know how smart I am now. You could ask her to name the biggest company in the world. And she would be like, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, giving you the exact right answer.
Brilliant. So good. Brilliant. Our writers are brilliant. We had a fan catch from Leah J. in Charleston, Indiana, who said, at five minutes 36 seconds, the whiteboard behind Kelly says, meeting with Chris, Nick and Ed. Is that referring to Nick the IT guy and who are Chris and Ed? Oh, hold up.
That's our camera crew. Yes. Chris and Ed were our assistant camera operators and our sound guy was Nick Carbone. Yep. Well, now we are going to meet Luke. Luke's going to show up with the coffee. He's gotten everyone's order wrong. Well, I was very surprised and I paused to make sure that we used real Starbucks cups.
Those were Starbucks. Yeah. How did we get away with that? I asked Randy about it and he said that at first this was flagged by standards and practices because if you want to use a real product, you have to clear it with the NBC ad sales department because if they had an advertiser who might be a competitor, then that person who had bought ad time would definitely not want to see free advertising on a show. Right.
Like if you're the guys at Pete's Coffee. Yeah. Or Coffee Bean, you're like, hey, hold on a second. Get that Starbucks out of there. Well, I guess coffee chains were not actually huge ad buyers at the time. Really? Yes. Wow.
That's what Randy said. That's how old we are. That's how old the show is. Yes. We had flip phones. We had Instagram and coffee companies weren't that big of a deal. Yeah. And so I guess there were no conflicts and we were able to get approval to use real Starbucks
cups. Wow. Mm-hmm. You know about the whole Starbucks cup on the set of Game of Thrones that made it into the Game of Thrones episode? I do. Mm-hmm. I can't believe they haven't gone back and wiped that out.
It's not like such a lore of the show that it's like an Easter egg that you're just going to keep it in for. It is coming and so is your Starbucks. There's now a series of talking heads that are really funny, but basically the theme is everyone hates Luke and that Luke sucks. Yeah. In the kitchen, Andy is going to confront Michael and just say, Luke is the worst. He needs to be fired, Michael.
But Michael's just kind of hedging. Oh, yeah. He's like, he's not that bad. That other intern we had was worse. Lady, I need to talk about this. Did you notice Steve's holding an apple in his scene. He's got a coffee in one hand and an apple in the other. I went to the script.
I'm like, did this apple have a story? No. It's just, I guess he went to the kitchen to get an apple. I thought it was interesting. This is like an interesting. Why is Michael holding an apple? Interesting choice. Well, I mean, I don't know.
Apple and coffee. Hmm. Sounds gross to me. We are now going to start a whole storyline that is really centered around Pam at the core. Dwight has this impressive ring of keys. I mean, it's ridiculous. That's huge.
He has all these keys. And Jim is doing basically classic Jim prankage. Yes. Jim has a bunch of extra keys in his desk. When he gets Dwight to go check for raccoons in the wall, he tries to add a few extra keys to the key ring. His goal is very similar to when he was putting the nickels in Dwight's phone receiver. Oh, amazing.
It's my favorite prank. Me too. He's going to put so many extra keys, like one a day to a day onto this key ring that eventually his pants will fall down. That was his goal. Well, Jim has a talking head that said, what happened to me this summer? Dwight bought the building. So actually, this has been the busiest summer of my life.
Yeah. He had to make plans. Lots of prank plans. Jim finds it hilarious and starts laughing in Dwight Bus Jim. Yeah. We had a fan question from Sarah C. in Lubbock, Texas. Does Rain throw real keys at John's head or are they fake keys? One of them hit him.
And you hear like a thump. I know. I was wondering the same thing. I swear they were real keys. Same. Because I have this memory. Rain was kind of throwing them at John's chest. Yeah.
Rain, but then I swear it was this take. One of them just accidentally kind of like flew at John's head and they stopped. And John was like, dude, and Rain was like, I'm so sorry. He's like, it's okay, but like those are real. And yes. So I totally have that memory of shooting that scene. But I think they're real too. I have the same memory.
And also if you watch John's reaction. Yeah. That's what I mean. Yeah. Well, you know, this is interesting because Pam feels really bad and Jim has bummed out that he's pranked it and go and BJ talked on the commentary about how they had to get creative with conflict scenes for Jim and Pam. Now that they're a happily married couple, I thought it was really interesting.
Let's listen. So this was something we thought of because we like when Jim and Pam have stories, but we don't want to invent fights. There are a couple that gets along really well and we like stories between them, but we don't always want them having conflict because that's not real. So what would be a light conflict? Right. Real, but not sad.
Yeah. Is that interesting that they had to find ways for Jim and Pam to have storylines and this sort of Pam trying to do right by Jim with this prank was one of those light conflict storylines. Well, we also had a fan catch from Ashley W in Oklahoma for the scene. You're going to like it, Angela. Okay. So that's what Ashley said, Pam's desk plant has a bow on it.
It's like a gift bow. Are these plants gifts from someone? Does she have a plant subscription box? Maybe that's why they were constantly changing. Wait, is there such a thing as a plant subscription box? I've never heard of that. Could I get plants sent to me every month? You've never heard of this?
No. It's like, you know, like cheese of the month, you can get flowers of the month, plant of the month. Wine of the month. Okay. Cheese, wine. I guess flowers make sense, but I didn't know you could get a whole living plant like in a pot.
I mean, I believe it. I want one. Okay. Plant subscription box. Come in your way, lady. Josh is going to be like, Angela, plants are all over the house. I had a flowers of the month. Lee got it for me for Christmas one year and every month I got fresh flowers.
It was so amazing. What a great gift. I know. Well, I'll tell you what, Ashley, I don't know if there was a subscription box, but I'll tell you my backstory for that plant. Do you remember when Jim let Pam's plant die on her desk when she went on maternity leave? So you think Jim bought Pam a new plant? I do.
Oh, I like that. And that's why there was a little bow on it. And I think she didn't take the bow off because it reminded her of Jim's thoughtfulness. I like that. Well there is someone in the office who you don't want to tick off and that is Phyllis. Oh, that's right. And Luke has crossed Phyllis. She lost an account because she's pretty sure Luke did not send the samples he was supposed
to. That's right. Lehigh Motors has not gotten their samples. He blows off Phyllis and then, you know, he's just like playing video games on Meredith's computer. Everyone's getting so frustrated with Luke, Michael sends him to get ice cream. And eight minutes and 49 seconds, Angela, you are not at your desk in the background of the scene.
I noticed. I thought I had gone to the bathroom. Where have you sneaked away to, lady? I probably talked our AD into letting me go to the bathroom like, they're not going to see me. I know. All right. We are 10 minutes into this episode and we are going to move to a scene in the conference
room. I noticed with the conference table. Yeah. Not the usual row of chairs. Table is back. People are going to figure out pretty quickly that Michael is related to Luke. Oscar accuses Michael of nepotism. This whole conference room scene is delicious and amazing.
During this rewatch, lady, I love our conference room scene. Same. I loved doing our conference room scenes. I used to feel bad for Steve because I knew how much work they were for him. We'd be in there all day and he would be the leader. He would be driving the scene. He would have the majority of the dialogue and all we had to do was chime in with a line or two here.
Basically, everyone that worked at Dunder Mifflin was always versus Michael. Yes. But they are delightful. I get so excited every time we go to the conference room. At 10 minutes and 19 seconds in this conference room scene, Rain is drinking water from his pouch. I swear to God, I remember that he drank real water from that pouch all day long. I remember he had to pee all day long.
No, it's true. He was not fakey drinking. He was not fakey drinking. Rain is very method as an actor. So if he was like, if Dwight's supposed to be drinking water, I'm going to be drinking lots of water. Creed has a talking head that I absolutely love. Creed says, I couldn't care less about nepotism, but I'm loving the debate.
Great minds battling it out and I've got a front row seat. So good. So good. I mean, I'm Creed. Really? You're like, I'm like, I'm loving it as well. Well, lady, maybe we should take a break. Yeah.
And when we come back, Luke is going to have soy ice cream and bagel chips for everybody. And there was a mini Michael Pam tangent that was cut from this conference room scene that I'm excited to share. Ooh. Well, we are back from break. Michael is continuing to defend Luke. He's even comparing himself and Luke to like God and Jesus. That's right.
And Jim has this line where he says, oh, so you and Luke are God and Jesus. And Michael says, no, not that. I'm just saying, why does God get to do something I don't? Why does God get to do nepotism, basically? And then Oscar says, this is all hypothetical. We're talking about Luke who is actually terrible. And I don't know if you noticed, lady, but 11 minutes, 48 seconds when Oscar says that line to Michael, I'm sort of smiling and shrugging like I have a sort of out of context body
energy. Yeah. Like reaction. And at first I thought, oh my gosh, am I breaking? And then I remembered, no, Pam and Michael had a bit because I suddenly had that like sense memory of shooting it and we were laughing like all these memories came back. So I checked the shooting draft and I found it. Here is what would have happened.
So Michael was going to say, why does God get to do something I don't? And then Pam says, Michael, you've built yourself up fair and square. How can you support favoritism like this? To which Michael said, Pam, let's say you're my daughter and I'm the CEO of the world's biggest toy company, Scott's games and fun. We make funny putty, magic marbles, connectables. And Dwight said, what are connectables? And Michael said, they're my knockoff Legos, almost as good half the price.
And I remember that was, we would lose it on this like connectables, like what are connectables? So anyway, then Michael would say, okay, one day I fall in the sliminator and die. And we would all laugh. Like we could not get through this runner of Michael's toy company. Oh my God, I'm remembering this because I remember also how well thought out it was. Yes. He's throwing it out as just an off the cuff example, but it is a well thought out toy company.
Yes. He says, Pam, I left you the company, would you turn it down? So in this example, Pam is Michael's daughter and Michael's created this insanely successful toy company, but he dies in the sliminator and has left her the company. He's Willy Wonka. He wants to know, would I turn it down? And Pam said, if I was unqualified, yes. To which Michael says, very seriously, but you're not.
You've got an amazing mind for toys. And then the script said, Pam looks flattered. Oh my gosh. And then Oscar said, this is all hypothetical. Oh, that's why he's not- Look on my face. But also why Oscar is saying this is all hypothetical. Yes. This toy company, but it's why when I'm sitting next to him on that line, I'm like, oh, well,
thank you very much. I want to see that I'm saying non-verbally, thank you very much, Michael. Like, Pam is like, oh, well, if you say so. That's right. Oh my gosh. I remember all of that now. Yes. Right?
It's like you opened a folder in my brain. Yes. Michael's toy company. And by the way, I went to the bloopers to see if it was in there because I know it wasn't in deleted scenes. It's not in there, but we were cracking up. They're somewhere. Somewhere.
Well, that was delightful trip down memory lane. I do want to address something though with Pam. Oh, she's about to have a talking head where she says she feels awful for blowing Jim's prank. Can we talk about how fancy fancy Pam is looking? What is with this hair? I noticed black eyeliner. I mean, fancy Pam.
You are not the only one, Angela. We got mail about it. We got a fan question from Kaylee E. in Indianapolis and Kristen H. from Little Rock, Arkansas. Pam's look takes a big shift this season, straighter hair, a tucked in shirt, more blazers than cardigans. Surely there were many meetings about this? Surely they were. Surely.
Surely. Surely there were. Surely. Yes. There were many meetings about this. Starting in wardrobe, I will tell you, we decided that we wanted Pam to keep her blazers, but we wanted to bring back more of what they would call Pam's color palette. So rather than having a dark shirt with a dark blazer, we wanted to bring the pastels back
because that really felt like Pam, the pinks and the lighter colors. The light purple. Yeah. So you're going to see that. And then in terms of the hair, I went to Kim Ferry and I said, Kim, I miss Pam's hair. I miss the Pam mullet, the half up, half down. Yeah. And we were changing Pam's hair because Pam's life was going through a lot of changes.
She broke up with Roy, she started dating Jim. She got this new job at Michael Scott Paper Company. She became a mom. And you also just changed your look over the years. You do. You do. Unless you were my grandmother who had the same hairstyle her whole life. Same with my grandmother.
But Pam, Pam is evolving. Well, I don't know about you, but in my life, I have always kind of had like a base hairstyle and I'll stray from it, but then I'll come back to it and I'll stray and I'll come back to it. And I felt like it was time for Pam to come home to her base hairstyle. But we also thought she's learned a lot about hair since that first frizzy half up, half down. And so now she's sleek half up, half down.
That's right. Well, I thought you looked beautiful. You and Pam looked fantastic. Well, I also got married over the summer and I had grown my hair out a little bit. I don't know. I could tell how happy I am in my life when this episode came on. And I feel like you can tell that newlywed energy in this episode and moving forward. Well, Michael is going to get a text and looks out the window.
Angela is waving at him. She looks hot to trot to come down to the parking lot. Her first line to him just made me laugh, lady. She says, I came down here to feed the feral cats like I usually do and I found something un-savory in the back of your nephew's car. What was it? All of the things that he was supposed to be like mailing and shipping, including Phyllis's samples, Oscars expense reports, and some pants that Michael wanted to return to Talbot's.
By the way, we got a fan catch from Mandy M. in Texas. Okay. I just said this. I have been holding on to this for so long. Many deep dive alert. Oh, I'm loving Mandy. Okay, Mandy. Let's have it.
Erin asked Michael about returning pants to Talbot's. Talbot's stopped carrying men's clothing in 2008, according to The New York Times. This episode aired in September 2010, two years after Talbot stopped carrying men's clothing. This must be another instance of Michael wearing women's clothing, which is an amazing callback to the negotiation. Oh, it's the first thing I thought of. I thought he's bought another woman's suit, without any pockets. And shoulder pads.
Exactly. Michael is going to get on a video call with Joe and for the majority of this call, all you see is Gabe's crotch until Joe is like, well, you've been down, so I don't have to look at your crotch. Oh, I wrote out what she said because her line read on that was so funny to me. She says, lower yourself, Gabe. I don't want to be having a conversation with your crotch. I loved it so much.
Angela, this reminded me of the day that we were working on our book over FaceTime. You remember? Yeah. Yeah. We would have this like FaceTiming writing sessions. But do you remember that time? We were like two hours into the FaceTime, and I look over and I realize that you've been like looking up my nose the entire two hours.
You did not say anything. I didn't say anything. We were busy both typing and writing, but I would check in with you and for two hours, the way you had your laptop sort of positioned, I just saw your neck and up your nose. I mean, for two hours, I was like, lady, this could have been a phone call. This could have, why are we on a video chat if you're looking at like my chin nose? It was crazy. I know.
I didn't say anything, but it did remind me of whenever I FaceTimed my mom and I see like her forehead and ceiling fan. Yes. I'm like, mom, tilt it down. During this Skype, when this exchange also made me laugh, when Joe says, why won't you fire Luke? And Michael says, I love him. She goes, oh no, how far has it gone?
Yeah. How far has it gone? Her line read on that, I mean, I rewound it. I watched it like four times. I know. The woman is brilliant. And Michael's like, he's my nephew. And Joe's like, I have a nephew too, but he doesn't work for me.
He'd screw it up. She says he can come swim in her pool, but he can't come in her house. And Michael says, well, this is my pool. And he wants his nephew to work in his pool. And then Joe says, well, that's fine, but it's on you, Michael. If he screws up, I'm going to hold you accountable, basically. So Michael is going to have a talking head about how he's trying to work side by side with Luke.
After this talking head, Jenna, there was a deleted scene that didn't make it in. It's on the DVD set. Michael calls his half sister, Luke's mom, to ask her advice on how to deal with Luke. I also went to the shooting draft because I wanted to know more about it. This is how it starts in the shooting draft. Michael is on the phone with his sister, Marnie. OK. So we know her name, Marnie.
He looks at his computer, which we don't see. And he says to Marnie, I'm so psyched you approved my friend request, Marnie. Oh, look, we have Nana in common. And Marnie says she posts constantly. The scene continues. I have it from the DVD. I want you to hear it. Oh, hey, how's Luke doing?
Oh, best nephew ever. Isn't he? He really, he changes the whole demeanor of the office. It's really such a joy having him here. He's really a joy. Oh, good. I just wanted to ask you a parenting question. A parenting question?
How do you deal with his? What? How do I deal with what, Michael? What? No, no, it's, he's great. He's fantastic. It's just, you know, when he has, he does this little attitude thing. What attitude?
No, not at, not, not attitude in a negative way. I'm talking like pink. You know how pink has an attitude? Or when a fashion photographer says, give me more attitude. That's what I'm talking about. He's great. He has a big, he just has a lot of. Attitude.
It's great. Okay. All right. Well, I'm glad it's working out. It's great. He is such a joy and a pleasure and a real gem. Okay. Great.
Well, you're the best, Michael. Well, thank you. That is awfully nice of you to say. And I just posted something on your wall. Okay. Thanks for saying I'm the best. Love your brother, Michael. There it is.
Uh, give Luca a hug for me. I'll give him a hug and a kiss. Just a hug. It's good. All right. How amazing is that? It's my favorite thing I've ever heard. I mean, you hear, you hear how well it starts and then how badly it ends.
呃，代我拥抱一下卢卡。我会给他一个拥抱和一个吻。只有一个拥抱。很好。好的。太棒了吧？这是我听过的我最喜欢的事情。我的意思是，你听听，你听听它的开始是多么顺利，然后它的结局又是多么糟糕。
It's so good, lady. So many layers. All right. Coming up is something I've also wanted to share with you. It's about Kevin and Pam by the elevators. Yes. Pam is going to do a very elaborate prank. She is rearranging the buttons on the elevator and then she's going to have Dwight, I guess,
真是太棒了，女士。有这么多的层次。好的。接下来是我也一直想和你们分享的内容。它是关于电梯旁的凯文和帕姆的。是的。帕姆要做一个非常精心的恶作剧。她正在重新排列电梯上的按钮，然后她打算让德怀特，我猜，
try to use this elevator. And she's going to film them and it's going to be hilarious because the elevator isn't going to do what you tell it to do. Kevin is rearranging the buttons. He is the elevator technician and we got a fan question from Leslie S. in San Francisco, California, that says, I've always been confused by Pam's choice to ask Kevin to help her change the elevator button controls. Does he have some background as an electrician?
试着使用这个电梯。她还要把他们拍下来，这一定会非常搞笑，因为电梯不会按照你指示的那样运作。凯文正在重新排列按钮。他是电梯技师，我们收到了来自加利福尼亚州旧金山的莱斯利·S的一位粉丝提问，上面写着，我一直对帕姆选择让凯文帮她更改电梯按钮控制感到困惑。他有什么电工背景吗？
I feel like Pam could figure this out more competently than Kevin. I mean, she did assemble a copier by herself. Exactly. And also, is Pam not worried when Kevin says, let me look at the circus board? Yeah. Exactly. Well, this was the much bigger storyline for Kevin that I hinted at earlier in the episode. It explains why Kevin is helping Pam with the elevator panel.
我觉得帕姆比凯文更能胜任这件事。我的意思是，她确实自己组装过一台复印机。没错。而且，当凯文说“让我看看电路板”时，帕姆难道不担心吗？对。没错。好吧，这就是我之前在本集节目中暗示过的凯文的那个更大的故事线。它解释了为什么凯文要帮帕姆处理电梯面板。
He shares in a talking head that over the summer, he decided to practice lying more. Oh, yeah. And he really got into it. I thought you were going to say over the summer he became an electrician. Oh, no, no, no. He just has decided to lie a lot. All right, listen. What?
他在一段单人访谈中分享说，在夏天，他决定练习更多的撒谎。哦，是的。他真的沉迷其中了。我以为你要说他在夏天成了一名电工。哦，不，不，不。他只是决定大量撒谎。好吧，听着。什么？
Oh, last night Jenny came over again and she cooked me dinner and then we had sex all night long. Gross. That's awesome, Kevin. It is. This summer, I decided to become a liar. I just make things up. It's going great.
哦，昨晚珍妮又过来了，她给我做晚饭，然后我们做爱了一整晚。真恶心。太棒了，凯文。确实如此。今年夏天，我决定成为一个骗子。我只是凭空捏造事情。进展很顺利。
That is amazing. Yeah. So he starts off lying and accounting, then he has this talking head saying that he's now a liar. It's working out great. And then he tells Pam what he's going to do to the elevator and then lies some more. Here, listen. How did you learn how to do this?
这太棒了。是的。所以他从在会计部门撒谎开始，然后他有了一段单人访谈，说他现在是个骗子。进展非常顺利。然后他告诉帕姆他要对电梯做什么，接着又撒了更多的谎。来，听着。你是怎么学会做这个的？
Before this job, I worked as an elevator repairman. I specialized in the buttons. Hey, did you SMS text message me? I just came from the museum where I saw an exhibit on rare coins. I've never worked as an elevator repairman. That's another lie. It's become a tangled web. I'm a bit worried I'm losing myself.
在这个工作之前，我曾是一名电梯修理工。我专门负责按钮。嘿，你给我发短信了吗？我刚从博物馆回来，在那里我看到了一个关于稀有硬币的展览。我从来没有当过电梯修理工。那是另一个谎言。这已经变成了一张错综复杂的网。我有点担心我正在迷失自我。
That is amazing. Well, what we see in the episode is Dwight just coming in and saying, Pam, I received your SMS message, old tech alert. What is she want, lady? We could not get through this. There was something about the way rain was entering as Dwight sucking on his water. And Brian and I, you know that thing where like rain wasn't in on it because me and Brian had had this whole thing like you just played of him explaining the circuit board what he
太棒了。好吧，我们在剧集中看到的是，德怀特刚走进来，然后说，帕姆，我收到了你的短信提醒，老科技警报。她想要什么，女士？我们简直无法继续录制了。德怀特一边吸着水，雨水进入的方式有些奇怪。我和布莱恩，你知道那种情况吗，就像雨水其实并不在状况内，因为我和布莱恩刚刚演了刚才你播放的那整段，他解释电路板的戏份。
was doing. And then Dwight walks in and it just made us laugh. And rain was like, what, what, why can we not continue? Okay. So the blooper for this is on the blooper reel for this season. But we were doing that laughing thing where we're not making any noise. Right. There's no point in playing it.
然后德怀特走进来，这直接把我们逗笑了。而雨水却说，什么，什么，为什么我们不能继续？好吧。所以这个NG镜头是在本季的NG花絮里。但我们在做那种笑的动作，却没有发出任何声音。对。播放它没有任何意义。
Yeah. It's just two people shaking. Exactly. But you know what? I'll post it. Okay. So people can see it. But anyway, eventually we get through this moment and Pam says to Dwight that she wants
是的。这只是两个人浑身发抖。完全正确。但你知道吗？我会把它发布出来。好吧。以便人们可以看到它。不过无论如何，我们最终熬过了这个时刻，帕姆对德怀特说她想
to show him something in the lobby and she gets in the elevator with him. She starts filming him. Oh, she's so excited. She's so tickled by this. Well, at first it works. You know, it starts going up instead of down, but then the elevator gets stuck and Dwight immediately pees in the corner immediately. He isn't like, oh, maybe I can hold it for a little bit.
在大厅里给他看点东西，然后她和他一起进了电梯。她开始拍他。哦，她太兴奋了。她对此感到开心极了。好吧，一开始它起作用了。你知道，它开始往上走而不是往下走，但接着电梯卡住了，德怀特立刻在角落里撒尿，立刻。他可没有觉得，哦，也许我能稍微憋一会儿。
It's like elevator doors don't open. What if they had opened two minutes later, mid P. Oh my gosh. He says, I have 56 ounces of fluid in my bladder. This made me curious. How much can a bladder hold? Did you Google that? I did. And I will tell you, according to Healthline, a healthy adult bladder can hold up to 16 ounces
这就像电梯门打不开一样。如果它们在两分钟后打开，也就是撒尿撒到一半的时候呢？哦，天哪。他说，我膀胱里有56盎司的液体。这让我很好奇。膀胱能装多少东西？你用谷歌查过吗？我查了。我会告诉你们，根据Healthline（健康热线）的说法，一个健康的成年人膀胱最多可以容纳16盎司
or two cups of urine. Dwight says he has 56 ounces of urine in his bladder. That's like five times more than a normal bladder. I didn't stop my search there. Just so you know, I became very curious because we have to pee all the time, lady. I know it's healthy. Here was one of the questions in this article. Is it safe to hold your pee?
或两杯尿液。德怀特说他的膀胱里有56盎司的尿液。那比正常膀胱多大约五倍。我的搜索并没有就此停止。为了让你们知道，我变得非常好奇，因为我们总是得去小便，女士。我知道这很健康。这篇文章里有这样一个问题：憋尿安全吗？
What did it say? It said that if you have a healthy urinary system, holding your pee generally isn't dangerous. But in certain circumstances, holding your urine for any length of time can be dangerous, like if you have one of the following conditions, enlarged prostate, neurogenic bladder, kidney disorders, or urinary retention. So then don't hold it. Okay. Do you know what happens to your body when you hold your pee?
它说了什么？它说，如果你有一个健康的泌尿系统，憋尿通常并不危险。但在某些情况下，憋尿任何时长都可能是危险的，比如如果你有以下某种情况：前列腺肥大、神经源性膀胱、肾脏疾病或尿潴留。所以那就不要憋着。好吧。你知道当你憋尿时你的身体会发生什么吗？
Oh God, no. It says when you feel the urge to empty your bladder, it isn't just because your bladder is filling up with liquid. It's actually a really complex process that involves a bunch of muscles and organs and nerves, and that this reaction gets set off in your body when your bladder is only about half full. So that's why you can hold it for a bit. Oh, because your bladder is like warning.
哦天哪，不知道。它说，当你感觉到排空膀胱的冲动时，这不仅仅是因为你的膀胱正在被液体充满。这实际上是一个非常复杂的过程序列，涉及一堆肌肉、器官和神经，并且当你的膀胱仅约半满时，这种反应就会在你的身体里被触发。所以这就是为什么你能憋一会儿。哦，因为你的膀胱在发出警告。
Yes. Warning. Exactly. Halfway full. And these signals kind of differ from person to person. And according to your age, or if you've had a kid, these nerves and whatnot can maybe... And the Hoosie was it. Yeah.
是的。警告。完全正确。半满。这些信号因人而异。根据你的年龄，或者如果你生过孩子，这些神经什么的可能会……还有那个什么玩意儿。是的。
And the what-nots might be different. That's exactly right. Also, the signals will decrease at night, and that's why you can... Sleep. But you wake up having a pee. That's right. Yeah. Because it won't signal you when your bladder is only half full.
还有那些乱七八糟的可能会有所不同。完全正确。此外，这些信号在夜间会减弱，这就是为什么你可以……睡觉。但你醒来时会有尿意。没错。是的。因为当你的膀胱只有半满时，它不会向你发出信号。
Mayday, yeah. But you know what you should do if you really need to hold your pee? There are some tips, if I don't know, lady, we need to hold it. Well, there's always some road trip where I have to hold it because there was no gas station. Here's what it says. Number one, do a task that will actively engage your brain, such as a crossword puzzle. Well, I can't do that in the car.
梅黛，是的。但如果你真的需要憋尿，你知道你应该怎么做吗？有一些小贴士，如果我不知道的话，女士，我们需要憋着。好吧，总有那么一次公路旅行，我必须憋着，因为没有加油站。这是它上面说的。第一，做一件能积极调动你大脑的任务，比如填字游戏。好吧，我在车里做不了那个。
I'll get nauseous. It says, listen to music. I can do that. Also, if you are already sitting, stay sitting. Don't stand up. Don't stand up. Oh, yeah. Cross your legs.
我会晕车的。它说，听音乐。这个我可以。另外，如果你已经坐着了，那就继续坐着。不要站起来。不要站起来。哦，是的。交叉双腿。
You could read a book. Can't do that in the car. Listen to this one. This is a suggestion. Scroll through social media on your phone. That'll help you not have to go to the bathroom. All of these things are going to make me sick in the car. Another thing is try to stay warm because being cold will give you the urge to urinate.
你可以看一本书。在车里可做不到。听听这个。这是一个建议。在你的手机上刷社交媒体。那会帮你不用去洗手间。所有这些事情都会让我在车里感到恶心。另一件事是尽量保持温暖，因为寒冷会给你带来排尿的冲动。
Any wonder I always feel like I have to pee. I know. I'm always cold. Yeah. You know, lady, when I do my cold dip, so I sit in really warm water and then I go to my cold dip. Do you have to pee? Yeah.
难怪我总觉得我想尿尿。我懂。我总是很冷。是的。你知道吗，女士，当我进行冷水浸泡时——所以我坐在非常温暖的水里，然后我去进行冷水浸泡。你得尿尿吗？是的。
When you get in the cold dip, it's like 60 degree water and it gives you this feeling like you have to pee even if you just peed. Whoa. I was going to ask you, have you ever been swimming in the ocean, anyone? This is open for anyone. Have you ever been swimming in the ocean and you have to pee and you tell your body, go pee. It's okay.
当你进入冷水浸泡时，那是大约60度的水，它会给你一种必须尿尿的感觉，即使你刚刚才尿过。哇。我要问你，你有没有在大海里游过泳，任何人？这是对所有人开放的。你有没有在大海里游过泳，然后你不得不尿尿，你告诉你的身体，去尿尿吧。没关系。
We're in the ocean. We float it away from other people. Go pee and your body's like, uh-uh, not doing it. My body won't pee in the ocean. I think it's the waves. I think it's just a weird thing, sensation. You've told your body, don't pee in the pool, don't pee in the pool. Don't pee in the bath.
我们在海里。我们离其他人很远，可以漂开。去尿尿吧，而你的身体却说，呃-呃，不干。我的身体才不在海里尿尿呢。我觉得是海浪。我觉得这只是一种奇怪的感觉。你告诉过你的身体，不要在游泳池里尿尿，不要在游泳池里尿尿。不要在浴缸里尿尿。
Don't pee in the bath. And then you get in the ocean, you're like, have at it and your body's like, near. I think it's the waves because I don't have a problem peeing in a lake. Oh. And then we go to Lake of the Ozarks and we'll like anchor the boat and you're in a cove and you're swimming. You swim away from everyone else or, you know, when you're younger, you pee right next to your sibling and you make them swim through the water.
不要在浴缸里尿尿。然后你进入大海，你就想，来吧，而你的身体却说，才不呢。我觉得是海浪，因为我在湖里尿尿就完全没有问题。哦。然后我们去奥沙克湖，我们会把船抛锚，你在一个小海湾里游泳。你游到离其他人很远的地方，或者，你知道的，当你年轻的时候，你就直接在你兄弟姐妹旁边尿尿，然后让他们从水里游过去。
What's that worm water? Wait, can you guys pee in the ocean? Oh yeah. You got no problem? Okay. So Jenna, that rules out your- Sam, Cassie. Yeah, we're both excellent peers over here.
那是什么温水？等等，你们能在海里尿尿吗？哦，是的。你完全没问题？好吧。所以珍娜，这就排除了你的——萨姆，卡西。是的，我们俩在这里都是优秀的尿尿能手。
I'm pee in the ocean. That rules out your wave theory, your scientific wave theory. That was, I was certain that's what it was. It was the waves of the ocean as well because I'll get ready. I'm like all ready to pee and then a wave comes and it like stops me. Yeah. I don't know. Well, okay.
我能在海里尿尿。这就排除了你的海浪理论，你的科学海浪理论。那是，我确信那就是原因所在。也是海浪，因为我会准备好。我差不多准备好尿尿了，然后一个海浪打过来，它就像阻止了我一样。是的。我不知道。好吧，好吧。
We don't know. We don't know. Can you pee in the ocean? New poll. I can. It just takes a lot of effort. Do you remember that thing that they would tell you? Did you hear this when you were a kid?
我们不知道。我们不知道。你能在大海里尿尿吗？新的民意调查。我能。只是需要付出很多努力。你还记得他们过去常对你说的那件事吗？你小时候听说过这个吗？
You go to the public swimming pool in your neighborhood or whatever. And they would say don't pee in the pool because if you do, it'll turn green. Oh, I was a lifeguard at the public pool. We would say that. Yeah, but that's not true, right? It doesn't really change a color. I mean, what is, that makes no sense. Maybe there's a chemical you can put in the pool.
你去你家附近的公共游泳池或者别的什么地方。他们会说不要在泳池里尿尿，因为如果你这么做了，水会变绿。哦，我是公共泳池的救生员。我们确实会这么说。是的，但那不是真的，对吧？它并不会真的变颜色。我的意思是，什么，这根本说不通。也许有一种化学物质你可以放进泳池里。
Ours were just like empty threats. So I'll look it up and I'll have an answer by the end of the episode. Oh, we're gonna, we're like debunking things or maybe confirming. Okay. So Michael is in the conference room. He's actually doing like a real presentation, like real work. They talked in the commentary that this was like some of the most professional like verbiage you hear Michael say in the whole entire series.
我们的只是空洞的威胁。所以我去查一下，我会在本集结束前给出答案。哦，我们要，我们就像是在揭穿一些事情，或者也许在证实。好的。迈克尔在会议室里。他实际上在做一场真正的演示，就像真正的工作一样。他们在评论音轨里讨论过，这就像是你在整个系列中听到迈克尔说出的最具专业术语的话之一。
But Luke is distracting everyone because he has one of those little laser pointer things. He points it at Oscar's head. He points it to Angela's boob. Michael kicks them out and then he points it into Andy's eyeball. We got a fan question from Elizabeth P in Toronto, Canada who said, was Luke shining a real laser at people or was it added later? It was a fake laser. Yeah, you can't do that.
但卢克分散了每个人的注意力，因为他拿着那些小激光笔之一。他把它照在奥斯卡的头上。他把它照在安吉拉的胸部。迈克尔把他们赶了出去，然后他把它照进了安迪的眼球里。我们收到了来自加拿大多伦多的伊丽莎白·P的粉丝提问，她说，卢克是在向人们照射真正的激光，还是后来添加的？那是假的激光。是的，你不能那样做。
You could not put a laser in someone's eyeball. That's a CGI laser is my guess. It was and Randy even sent us like the little video of them adding it in. Michael is going to run out of the conference room to try to take the laser pointer away from Luke since he's being such a tool with it and this awkward physical altercation ensues. Michael starts spanking Luke spanking him. Yeah. On the desk and everyone in the conference room is watching this lady after watching
你不能把激光射进别人的眼球里。我猜那是CGI激光。确实是，而且兰迪甚至给我们发了他们添加特效的小视频。迈克尔要跑出会议室，试图从卢克手里夺过激光笔，因为他拿着这东西太像个混蛋了，接着就发生了这场尴尬的肢体冲突。迈克尔开始打卢克的屁股，打他屁股。是的。在桌子上，会议室里的每个人都在看着这个，女士，在观看了
the deleted scenes. When Michael is spanking Luke, all I can think about is his sister Marnie. Yes. How is Michael? She will never she will never speak to him again. Yes. Luke is going to run out crying and Michael comes back into the conference room. We had a fan question from Sessia Z in London, Ontario, Canada at 18 minutes 40 seconds.
被删减的场景后。当迈克尔在打卢克的屁股时，我满脑子想的都是他的姐姐玛尼。是的。迈克尔会怎样？她永远不会——她永远不会再跟他说话了。是的。卢克哭着跑了出去，迈克尔走回了会议室。我们收到了来自加拿大安大略省伦敦市的塞西娅·Z在18分40秒时的粉丝提问。
There's a quick pan of the camera, but if you pause it, you can clearly see Jim Phyllis and Daryl smiling or maybe breaking. And then as the camera pans, you can see Stanley smiling as well. Was this scripted or was everyone actually reacting to the scene and trying not to laugh? All right. I looked at this. Everyone's breaking. I don't know what happened, like what everybody is reacting to, but probably Steve did this
镜头有一个快速的摇移，但如果你暂停，你可以清楚地看到吉姆、菲利斯和达尔文在笑，或者说可能是在破功（笑场）。然后随着镜头摇移，你也可以看到斯坦利在笑。这是剧本安排的，还是每个人其实都是在对现场做出反应并极力忍住不笑？好的。我看过这个。所有人都破功了。我不知道发生了什么，就像大家都在对什么做出反应一样，但可能史蒂夫做出了
like very funny entrance to the conference room and it was making people break because you can also see Ed breaking. It's like a group break. The whole, the whole scene was just so huge and crazy and we were all just like, I think we were laughing, nervous, laughing. We were all just like, Oh my God, what's happening? Yes. Well, on the commentary, BJ and Paul talked about the moment they knew this whole Luke
非常搞笑的进入会议室的动作，这让大家破功了，因为你也可以看到埃德在破功。这就像是一场集体破功。整个，整个场景就是那么盛大而疯狂，我们当时都觉得，我想我们当时在笑，紧张地笑。我们当时都觉得，哦天哪，发生什么事了？是的。好吧，在评论音轨中，BJ和保罗谈到了他们知道整个卢克
Michael storyline was going to have a payoff and work. And in particular, they talked about whose idea it was for Michael to spank Luke. Into this. It wasn't until we had this scene that we figured we could, this episode worked. Yeah. In the writing stage. Yes. In the albumic stage.
和迈克尔的故事线将会得到回报并发挥作用的时刻。特别是，他们谈到了让迈克尔打卢克屁股是谁的主意。进入这个。直到我们拍了这场戏，我们才觉得我们可以，这一集成功了。是的。在剧本创作阶段。是的。在专辑制作阶段。
Yeah. I was, I was sitting in editing. You came in with a note card. From written by Aaron. Sure. You're in my shirt. Michael Spank. Michael Spank's Luke.
是的。我当时，我当时正坐在剪辑室里。你拿着一张便签走了进来。由亚伦写的。当然。你在我的衬衫里。迈克尔打屁股。迈克尔打了卢克的屁股。
Yeah. And you said, we got it. That's very funny. I texted Aaron and I was like, Aaron, is this true? And he goes, yeah, I'm pretty sure that's right. I love it. Well, now we're going to go back over to the elevator Bay Dwight and Pam are stuck. They've managed to get a technician, a real technician who was played by Tom Melby.
是的。然后你说，我们搞定了。这太搞笑了。我给亚伦发短信说，亚伦，这是真的吗？他说，是的，我确信那是对的。我太喜欢了。好吧，现在我们要回到电梯厅，德怀特和帕姆被困住了。他们设法找来了一名技术员，一名由汤姆·梅尔比扮演的真正技术员。
Yes. Tom Melby was our stage manager. He was there the whole entire run of the show. He basically knew everything about the property where we filmed and could fix anything. And I love that we put him in this episode working on the elevator. They said in the commentary that Tom was so shy and that's why he kind of kept his head tucked down. Well, you know, this was a fake elevator.
是的。汤姆·梅尔比是我们的舞台经理。他在整个剧集拍摄期间一直都在。他基本上了解我们拍摄地点的所有事情，并且能修理任何东西。我很高兴我们让他在这集里出演修理电梯的工作人员。他们在评论音轨中说，汤姆非常害羞，这就是为什么他总是把头埋得很低。好吧，你知道，这是一个假电梯。
This was not real. And so this was a huge elaborate thing that they had to build of us being stuck between floors, being up high like that with that little opening. Like all of it, you know, even earlier, you know, we've said the elevator doors opened and closed because there was a crew person like doing a rope on a pulley. So when we had that whole moment before when the elevator's breaking down, that was a very elaborate set of like someone was shaking the elevator. Someone was pulling on the pulleys.
这不是真的。所以这是一个巨大的、精心制作的东西，他们必须建造它，让我们被困在楼层之间，高高地站在那里，带着那个小开口。就像所有这些，你知道的，甚至在早些时候，你知道的，我们说过电梯门打开和关闭是因为有一个剧组成员在滑轮上拉绳子。所以当我们之前有电梯抛锚的整段戏时，那是一套非常精心制作的装置，比如有人在摇晃电梯。有人在拉滑轮。
It was like very like old timey. I was going to say, it sounds like a vaudeville show. Yes. That's kind of what it was. But we actually shot this broken elevator in a completely different spot. It wasn't even in our little lobby. It was over on the warehouse stage on stage four. They recreated the lobby, Michael Gallenberg designed it, Tim James built it.
这就像是非常老派的风格。我本来想说，听起来像是一个杂耍表演。是的。差不多就是那样。但我们实际上是在一个完全不同的地方拍摄这个坏掉的电梯的。它甚至不在我们那个小大厅里。它在四号摄影棚的仓库布景里。他们重建了大厅，迈克尔·盖伦伯格设计的，蒂姆·詹姆斯建造的。
And it was on a platform that was about four feet above the stage. I just remember it was like this really cool thing that they had to build. And then I had to stand up there. We really were high up. Yeah, you really were. I have a question for you, Angela. So in the scene where Pam's stuck in the elevator with Dwight, Jim comes over. She's so proud of herself.
它在一个高出舞台大约四英尺的平台上。我只记得这是他们必须建造的一个非常酷的东西。然后我不得不站在那里。我们真的是在高处。是的，你们真的是。我有一个问题要问你，安吉拉。所以在帕姆和德怀特被困在电梯里的那场戏里，吉姆走了过来。她为自己感到无比骄傲。
She says, they don't call me the Bart Simpson of Scranton for nothing. Jim says, here, I'll help you down. And she says, nope, it's okay. I'm afraid of getting cut in half. I have a question, okay. If you were stuck like Pam, would you go through the little opening or would you be afraid of being cut in half? I mean, I don't want to be cut in half.
她说，他们叫我斯克兰顿的巴特·辛普森可不是白叫的。吉姆说，来吧，我拉你下来。她说，不，没关系。我怕被腰斩。我有一个问题，好吧。如果你像帕姆一样被困住，你会穿过那个小开口，还是会害怕被腰斩？我的意思是，我不想被腰斩。
But I think in that moment, I would just want out. So I think I would go for it. If I could just slip right out there, I'd probably go for it. I don't think I would do it because I would just think of that scene and speed. Yes. When they're stuck in the elevator and they're having the people come through. Yeah. And it keeps falling.
但我认为在那一刻，我只想出去。所以我认为我会去尝试。如果我能直接从那里滑出去，我可能会去试一试。我想我不会这么做，因为我会想起《生死时速》里的那个场景。是的。当他们被困在电梯里，让人们穿过来的时候。是的。而且它一直在下坠。
You can't hesitate. It keeps falling. Is that it? You can't hesitate. I mean, they had to have me say that because they wanted the visual comic gag of like me being in this broken elevator. Why is Pam not coming out? I probably would have already crawled out if those guys would have let me.
你不能犹豫。它一直在下坠。是这样的吗？你不能犹豫。我的意思是，他们不得不让我这么说，因为他们想要那种视觉喜剧效果，比如我待在这个坏掉的电梯里。为什么帕姆不出来？如果那些家伙肯让我出去的话，我可能早就爬出来了。
That's very funny. Well wrapping up this episode, Michael has earned the respect of his coworkers. Luke was a real problem and he got rid of Luke and they're happy about it. They have a whole scene where they're pretending to spank each other. However, Gabe is not happy that Michael assaulted an employee at work. And to deal with it, he tells Michael he's going to need to attend six counseling sessions. And Michael's like, that's it? No problem.
这太搞笑了。好了，总结这一集，迈克尔赢得了同事们的尊重。卢克是个真正的问题，他摆脱了卢克，他们对此很高兴。他们有一整场戏，假装互相拍打屁股。然而，加布对迈克尔在工作场所袭击员工感到不高兴。为了处理这件事，他告诉迈克尔他需要参加六次心理咨询。而迈克尔却说，就这样？没问题。
Except your counselor will be Toby. What? It's literally be fired or do six counseling sessions with Toby and Michael isn't sure what he wants. He really takes a long lingering look. And on the commentary, they said that was Steve, that choice to make that look of like, well, should I just call it quits? This is going to lead into next week's episode, which is that counseling session between Michael
除非你的咨询师是托比。什么？这简直就是被开除或者和托比进行六次心理咨询二选一，而迈克尔并不确定他想要什么。他真的深深地、依依不舍地看了一眼。在评论音轨中，他们说那是史蒂夫的主意，做出那种眼神，就像是，好吧，我是不是该就此收手？这将引入下一周的剧集，也就是迈克尔
and Toby. It is delicious. Before we go, Angela, we got this letter from Catherine P. and Bellevue, Nebraska. And it really touched my heart. So I wanted to share. Okay. Catherine said, I wanted to tell you that this episode is incredibly meaningful to my family.
和托比之间的那次心理咨询。太美妙了。在我们离开之前，安吉拉，我们收到了来自内布拉斯加州贝尔维尤的凯瑟琳·P的一封信。它真的触动了我的心。所以我很想分享一下。好吧。凯瑟琳说，我想告诉你们，这一集对我的家庭有着极其重要的意义。
I started watching the office on Netflix when I was pregnant with my oldest and just found out she would need heart surgery after she was born. It was not only a lifesaver, but fast forward to my daughter born and waiting for surgery. On her bad days, we would watch this episode specifically. My husband and entire family know that season seven, episode one is the lip dub. My daughter would smile and light up for her favorite faces singing just for her. She had surgery at four months old right before Christmas. The office kept us going during a very hard time for our little warrior.
当我怀着大女儿时，我在Netflix上开始看《办公室》，刚刚得知她出生后需要做心脏手术。这不仅是救命稻草，快进到我女儿出生并等待手术的日子。在她状态不好的日子里，我们就会专门看这一集。我丈夫和整个家族都知道第七季第一集是唇语配音秀。每当听到为她专属演唱的最爱面孔时，我女儿就会微笑并双眼放光。她在四个月大时、也就是圣诞节前夕做了手术。在我们的这位小勇士经历非常艰难的时期里，这部剧一直支撑着我们。
I took pictures of her laying in her swing, pleased as punched to be watching the lip dub for what had to have been the thousandth time. She is now a thriving and perfectly healthy eight year old, and we are forever grateful to the Scranton branch. PS, she had an opportunity to meet Kate Flannery several years ago and she hasn't stopped talking about it since. That just made me tear up. I know.
我拍下了她躺在秋千上的照片，高兴得不得了，正津津有味地看着这绝对已经是看了一千遍的唇语配音秀。她现在是一个蓬勃发展且完全健康的八岁孩子，我们对斯克兰顿分公司永远心存感激。附言，她几年前有机会见到了凯特·弗兰纳里，从那以后她就一直在谈论这件事。这直接让我流泪了。我知道。
Catherine, can we please send your daughter some office lady stuff? We would love to send her something. Thank you so much for sharing that. I'm so glad that our show could be there for you and your family. Yeah, I love it that this episode specifically has a special place in your heart. Catherine, we're going to email you, be on the lookout for it. Well, you guys, that was nepotism. Sam is waving at us.
凯瑟琳，我们能给你女儿寄一些“办公室女士”的周边吗？我们很乐意给她寄点东西。非常感谢你分享这个。我很高兴我们的节目能陪伴你和你的家人度过难关。是的，我很高兴这一集对你来说有着特别的意义。凯瑟琳，我们会给你发邮件的，请注意查收。好了，各位，那是裙带关系。萨姆在向我们挥手。
Sam, what do you got? Did you find out about peeing in the pool? I did. If you look up at the TV, I believe you'll find your answer. Oh, all right. Here it is. Does a swimming pool urine detecting dye actually exist? It says no such chemical is used.
萨姆，你有什么发现？你查到关于在泳池里尿尿的事了吗？我查到了。如果你抬头看电视，我相信你会找到答案的。哦，好的。在这里。游泳池尿液检测染料真的存在吗？上面说根本没有使用这种化学物质。
It doesn't exist. But 52% of people believe there is a chemical that when added to a pool will turn your urine into color. You guys, we basically all believed our moms are people at the public pool. It goes on to say, regardless, pools are not meant to be peed in because urine contains bacteria that you would not want to swim in. Please do not pee in pools. There you have it guys.
它根本不存在。但52%的人相信存在一种化学物质，当它被加入泳池时，会让你的尿液变色。各位，我们基本上都相信了我们妈妈或公共泳池里的人说的话。它接着说，无论如何，泳池不是用来尿尿的，因为尿液含有你绝对不想在其中游泳的细菌。请不要在泳池里尿尿。你们看，就是这样。
Yeah, it won't turn a color, but you shouldn't do it anyway. Well that was nepotism. Yeah. Thank you for listening. We love you guys. Thank you to Randy Cordray, Matt Sohn, Dave Rogers, Kate Flannery, Creed Bratton, and Aaron Scherr for letting us reach out to you about this episode. And thank you for sending in your questions and comments.
是的，它不会变色，但你无论如何都不应该这样做。好了，那是裙带关系。是的。谢谢你们的收听。我们爱你们。感谢兰迪·科德雷、马特·索恩、戴夫·罗杰斯、凯特·弗兰纳里、克里德·布拉顿和亚伦·舍尔，允许我们联系你们来聊聊这一集。谢谢你们发来的问题和评论。
Next week we are going to have a rerun of Beach Games, and then the following week we will have an all new episode, Counseling. See you then, bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe.
下周我们将重播《海滩游戏》，接下来的那周我们将带来一集全新的节目《咨询》。到时候见，拜拜。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿演奏的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月的Stitcher Premium，请使用代码 OFFICE。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。